Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich bin dran auf fertig essen.
Es sei denn ihr wollt ein ASMR-Eating-Sound-Stream.
Null.
Und schon jemand da?
Wo sind die Abo-Box-Camper?
Falls es sowas gibt auf Twitch.
Progers.
So Leute.
Fertig fuddern.
Komischen Appel da. Braucht eh keiner.
Obst 2k18.
Fast 19.
Oh, ich muss mal gucken, was mein Kompilierungszeug macht.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen würden.
Mein Kompilierungszeug.
Muss das alles geil aussprechen.
Nur weil das geil ausspricht, ja.
Kann was.
So ein Text ausblenden.
Deswegen mag ich mein Memeboard-Overlay.
Einfach weil ich die Bilder selbst sehe und nicht vergesse.
Ja, moin an die ganzen Abo-Box-Camper, die schon am Start sind.
Laut Twitch sind es ergeblich 8 Leute.
Twitch verschickt ja erst die Benachrichtigungen, gefühlt immer so eine Viertelstunde später.
Das heißt, alle die da sind, sind richtige Abo-Box-Camper.
Was ich natürlich sehr nice finde, darf ich nicht vergessen.
Kann ich gleich noch den Amazon-Ref-Link hinterherhauen.
Den wir gestern generiert haben.
So.
Ja, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss erst mal warten, bis das Stream richtig angelaufen ist.
Bis alle Notifiled sind und so weiter.
Guck mir mal, wie weit mein FFmpeg-Kompil-Vorgang auf meinem Raspberry Pi Zero ist.
Und ich habe gedacht, ich bin mal wagemutig und ich kompiliere FFmpeg auf dem Raspberry Zero.
Zero W, bitte schön.
Nein, ich will nicht neu starten.
Ah, nicht Exclusive-Mode.
Mal gucken, wie weit wir sind.
Nochmal hier wieder ein schöner Anwendungsfall für T-Max.
Ausgelockt, eingelockt.
Und jetzt gucke ich, wie weit das ist.
Meine Session wieder da von früher.
Und der ist noch am Kompilen des Todes, ey.
Der hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Da sieht man hier irgendwie, wie weit er ist.
Er hat schon ein bisschen kompiled, ja.
Wenn man sich hier den Output hier anguckt, vielleicht wird es irgendwann heute noch fertig.
Aber in dem Tempo, wie der hier kompiliert, das dauert bis morgen, ja.
Der ist High Speed.
Dann loggen wir uns mal wieder aus.
Und machen die VM zu.
So, und zwar was wir heute machen wollen ist, ich habe es ja gestern schon gesagt,
ich habe mir so eine billige China-Kamera gekauft.
So eine, ich habe sie irgendwie für 75 oder 85, ich glaube 85 Euro.
Ach, keine Ahnung, für die Hälfte oder so gekriegt.
Das ist so eine Kamera mit Mikrofon und Lautsprecher drinnen.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe es euch ja gestern schon gezeigt, das war ein Riesenakt,
das Ding in Betrieb zu nehmen, beziehungsweise es funktioniert auch nicht so richtig,
weil entweder brauchst du die offizielle App und wenn du die offizielle App,
die offizielle App ist übelste China-Crap, die willst du eigentlich nicht haben.
Und die andere Sache ist, man kann das Web-Interface verwenden,
aber das Web-Interface braucht ActiveX im Jahr 2018.
Was natürlich schon der komplette Witz ist, absoluter Witz.
So, und wir starten heute nicht komplett from scratch,
sondern ich habe ein paar Sachen aus anderen Sachen, die wir hier schon gemacht haben im Streamer, gerippt.
Zum Beispiel diese FFM-Pack-Decoder-Geschichte, das haben wir ja schon mal gebastelt vor einer Weile.
Da war es ein GIF-Decoder, aber jetzt ist es halt ein H.264-Decoder,
das kann es den FFM-Pack ja relativ einfach machen.
Was wir heute probieren wollen ist, das ist ja nicht nur eine Kamera, das ist eigentlich eine Gegensprechanlage.
Ich zeige euch mal das Ding.
Ich habe es bestimmt in der History irgendwie, ich hatte es gestern schon mal auf.
Das ist das Ding Hic-Vision, das Ding, die Vandal-Resistant-Doorbell, das Ding.
Und das hat hier vorne eine Kamera, das hat Nachtsicht, das hat eine Infrarot-LED dran und so einen Klingelknopf.
Die Sache ist die, wie gesagt, das geht nur mit offizieller App, aber die offizielle App ist halt übelster China-Crap,
dass man Kamera plus Gegensprechanlagefunktionen verwendet oder aber ActiveX.
Und ActiveX, ich zeige es euch mal für alle, die es gestern nicht gesehen haben, das will man eigentlich nicht verwenden.
Das ist abartig.
Außerdem geht das auch nur auf eine Windows-PC mit Internet Explorer.
Ja, das Ding ist hässlich, das ist definitiv nicht die schönste Kamera,
aber von der Funktion her für, es sieht schon echt scheiße aus, für irgendwie unter 100 Euro, 85 Euro, das ist echt in Ordnung.
So, ich finde das lustig.
Jetzt, ich sehe jetzt auch, gerade die Zuschauer sind quasi von 5 auf 30 gesprungen, so gefühlt.
Das ist, Twitch verschickt echt so, es ist leicht delayed, die Benachrichtigung immer.
Und wir haben übrigens Quality-Options, habt ihr das schon gesehen?
Quality-Options, ich bin wahrscheinlich mittlerweile wichtig genug auf Twitch und habe genug Zuschauer, dass ich Quality-Options kriege.
Oder aber, ich werde gebated.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass ich nächstes Mal wieder keine Quality-Options habe.
Möglich ist alles, man weiß es nicht.
Oder aber es sind einfach nicht genug wichtige Leute am Start, dass ich Quality-Options kriege.
Und dann wieder, jetzt ist es von ein paar an 30 auf 50 Zuschauer gesprungen, ist doch geil.
Erklärst du heute die Sicherheitslegalität, die du letztens in irgendeiner Kamera entdeckt hast?
Ja, da kann ich eigentlich, ne, also das hatte ich nicht vor, aber da kann ich auch was dazu sagen.
Weil, der Hersteller hat bis heute da nicht drauf reagiert.
Kann ich so etwas zuerst sagen.
Also doch, das stimmt nicht, er hat drauf reagiert, aber er hat eben vor drei Monaten oder so gefühlt schon gesagt, es gibt bald ein Firmware-Update, es gab immer noch kein Firmware-Update.
So, und wie gesagt, das ist die Kamera und ich habe hier schon ein bisschen Traffic von der Kamera mitgeschnitten.
Und das habe ich euch gestern auch schon gezeigt.
Gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an, dass wir wissen, was wir jetzt programmieren müssen.
Und das Problem ist, man sieht es hier an der Kamera, die geht nur mit ActiveX.
Und ActiveX ist halt einfach mal absoluter Crap.
Das war schon immer Crap und im Jahr 2018, quasi fast 2019 ist es nochmal besonders großer Crap.
Ich habe übrigens was vorne drauf geklebt auf die Kamera, dass ich mich hier nicht unabsichtlich reveal im Streben.
Weil ich muss die Kamera ja quasi hier direkt vor mein Gesicht legen, so in your face, dass ich die Gegensprechfunktion verwenden kann.
So, also das sind die Optionen, die man halt hat mit dieser Kamera.
Entweder ActiveX Internet Explorer Oberfläche im Jahr 2018.
Oder offizielle China App, die für Mobile Sachen, das ist die schlimmste App, die es gibt.
Diese Hequition App, das ist da Wahnsinn, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man das verwenden soll.
Deswegen werden wir jetzt versuchen, was eigenes zu basteln.
Und zwar wir fangen mal relativ bescheiden, fangen wir mal an.
Und zwar wir versuchen, der Kamera jetzt als erstes mal einen Sound unter zu schieben.
Sag mal, was ist mit dem Streben ein, mit dem Musikstreben los, der wird lauter und leiser und...
Nee, das ist einfach die Musik, die so komisch ist.
Oder auch nicht.
Merkwürdig.
Streams, vor allem Audio-Streams, die quasi Lautstärke-Schwankungen haben, sind ganz schlimm.
Ich glaube, das war einfach gerade vorbei.
So, und wie gesagt, wir fangen mal ganz bescheiden an.
Wir versuchen, der Kamera jetzt mal einen Sound unter zu schieben,
den ich schon in das richtige Format konvertiert habe.
Und dann versuchen wir, das hier nachzubasteln, was ich von der offiziellen App mitgeschnitten habe.
Also das wird noch witzig, weil das ist absolut nicht null standardkonform.
Ich habe es ja gestern schon mal kurz erzählt, also den Traffic, den wir hier sehen,
den dürfte es bis auf die ersten zwei Sachen gar nicht geben zwischen dem offiziellen Tool.
Und der Kamera. Das hier ist eine Anfrage, die der ActiveX Browser Client schickt an die Kamera,
die Http, die Kamera antwortet, und danach müsste es eigentlich eine neue Anfrage geben.
So ist das, dass es so wie Http funktioniert.
Aber nein, danach kommt irgendwie Raw-TCP-Geschwubbel.
Ich weiß nicht, das sind so Web-Sockets für Arme, das sind so Web-Sockets,
also die China Web-Sockets sind das, keine Ahnung. Das geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Und ich habe es schon mal vor ein paar Tagen ganz kurz versucht, in C-Sharp sowas zu basteln,
an die Kamera was zu schicken.
Und ich habe es nur so ein bisschen hingekriegt, weil die ganzen Http-Library-Sachen
und Tools, die in.NET eingebaut sind,
lassen mich das nicht machen, was die Chinesen hier machen.
Ich darf das hier nicht machen, weil das sagt,
Protokoll-Violation, Access-Violation, Exception ohne Ende,
weil korrekterweise möchten diese Sharp-Libraries, dass Http eben so verwendet wird, wie es gedacht ist.
Anfrage, Antwort.
Anfrage? Also es gibt in Http nicht sowas wie Anfrage, Antwort,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es nennen soll. Es gibt es nicht.
So, und wie gesagt, ich habe schon ein bisschen was geklaut von dem Meme-Board,
von dem Teil, das die GIFs anzeigt, also das das hier macht,
und habe es umgebaut für einen RTSP-Stream von der Kamera mit einer wahnsinnig hochgesicherten
Username-Passport-Kombination. Und wenn wir das starten, sieht das aktuell so aus von der Kamera,
dann kriegen wir nämlich noch das Formfenster mit Kamerabild und Bildfehlern ab und zu mal.
Aber das liegt an der Kamera. Man sieht nichts, weil ich was draufgeklebt habe.
Aber man sieht hier die Überblendung von der Kamera, also wir sehen, wir haben auch wirklich den
Stream von der Kamera hier abgegriffen. So, und jetzt machen wir uns mal einen Bucken hier unten hin.
Und dann sagen wir mal Play Sound oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann probieren wir mal, diese hässliche Ausgeburt von chinesischem,
von chinesischer Programmierung nachzubauen. Weil nur so funktioniert die Kamera,
beziehungsweise nur so funktioniert das Two-Way-Audio,
also die Gegensprechfunktion. Das heißt, heute müssen wir mehrere Schritte machen.
Und zwar als erstes versuchen wir mal einen Sound abzuspielen auf der Kamera.
Ich zeige euch noch mal was. Ich zeige euch noch mal was.
Ich hoffe, ich habe FFmpeg installiert.
Haben wir FFmpeg installiert? FFmpeg?
Also wir haben FFmpeg, aber auch FFBROBE haben wir auch installiert, sehr schön.
Das heißt, wir brauchen mehrere Schritte, die wir machen müssen.
Das heißt, als erstes versuchen wir mal einen Sound abzuspielen.
Danach versuchen wir den Sound von der Kamera abzurufen und abzuspielen lokal.
Ja, Timbo hat für chinesisch programmiert.
Except, man beachte, except language, chinesisch.
Sonst geht es nicht.
So, und der nächste Schritt ist dann, dass wir versuchen das Mikrofon zu captchern von meinem Rechner
und dann den Mikrofon-Output zur Kamera dingsen.
Ich muss bloß gucken, dass ich die Kamera nicht allzu nah hier dranlege,
sonst gibt es dann spätestens bei dem Punkt irgendwelche Rückkopplungen und euch fliegen die Ohren weg.
Und ich hoffe, dass, weil ich jetzt hier ein bisschen Audio-Zeug mit Windows machen muss,
ich hoffe, dass wir da nicht OBS irgendwie in die Quere kommen und OBS killen oder so.
Glaube ich zwar nicht.
Wir machen nichts direkt mit OBS, aber vielleicht beim Zugriff aufs Mikrofon oder sowas,
dass man keine Ahnung, dass man in Windows nicht zwei Applikationen aus dem Mikrofon gleichzeitig zugreifen lassen kann oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Oh, riesen Comment hier.
Brauche ich in einer halben Stunde zu lesen.
Hallo Wupplors, lurke dich auf YouTube schon ewig und danke für den ganzen Content.
Es sei es, wenn dir das gefällt, das ist doch die Hauptsache.
Was fallst du nebenbei wenigstens einen kurzen Denkanstoß für meine Probleme?
Lösungen hast was außer ein paar Problemen?
Moment, ich kann gerade nicht lesen, ich bin nicht in der Lage.
Was außer ein Problem des Spielkleinen könnte Memory Leaks hervorrufen,
wenn ein Spiel x alle anderen laufen super, sobald ich in-game bin, online, FPS, Shooter laufen meine 69.
Was?
Nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Du hast das Problem, dass bei Spielen dein Ramp voll wird.
Oder nur bei einem, nur bei einem, ne?
Wahrscheinlich Pubke oder sowas, da willst du mich nicht wundern.
Ja, auf meiner das stimmt, ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es funktioniert.
Glaub ich auch.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal die Kamera hier auf dem Schreibtisch stellen, warte mal kurz.
Ich mach jetzt mal hier das Cram vom Stream an.
Gucken ob man wenigstens ein paar Helligkeit Veränderungen sieht, wenn ich die Kamera hier rum rufe.
Wie ist eigentlich die Lautstärke so?
Lautstärke auch, ok.
Ja, man sieht so, wie sie sich hier bewegen.
Ja, die Kamera hat ein paar Übertragungsfehler, aber da kann ich nichts für.
Ja, ich greife das einfach nur ab.
China Kamera, Billig China Cram.
Man sieht die Ram Auslassung.
Ja, also wegen deiner Ram Auslassungsprobleme, da willst du relativ wenig machen können.
Weil wenn das nur bei einem Spiel ist und das ganz klar mit einem Spiel in Zusammenhang gebracht werden kann.
Also das Problem liegt auf jeden Fall am Spiel.
Aber es kann natürlich auch verursacht werden durch eine besondere Kombination, die du in deinem Rechner hast.
Und das ist dann dadurch irgendwie Memory Leaks verursacht oder was auch immer.
Ich meine, Memory Leaks sind immer und das ist das einzige, was leaken kann, ist die Anwendung an sich.
Wenn eine Anwendung vom Betriebssystem sagt, ich will Arbeitsspeicher haben.
Und dann wieder sagt, ich will Arbeitsspeicher haben.
Ohne den, den sie vorher angefragt hat, wieder zu sagen, komplett zu sagen, ich brauche hier nicht mehr.
Und was anderes kann ich Memory Leaken, weil das sieht man auch daran, sobald man die Anwendung abschießt, ist der Ram wieder frei.
Also das heißt, das Betriebssystem oder irgendwas sonst was leakt keine Memories.
Wo du natürlich richtig Probleme hast, sind, wenn wirklich irgendwelche Betriebssystems Sachen dann leaken, aber das machen sie in der Regel eigentlich nicht.
Oder wenn du Pech hast, die NVIDIA driver, dann hast du auch gelitten.
Aber das scheint mir in dem Fall wirklich spielbezogen zu sein.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich, ich meine, Escape vom Taghoff ist jetzt ja auch nicht dafür bekannt, dass das sonderlich krass optimiert wäre.
Ich habe da auch schon Dinger gelesen, dass das nicht sonderlich gut läuft.
Das ist wohl kein zweites Pupke, was die Performance angeht, aber wohl auch weit davon entfernt übelst geil zu sein.
Battlefield 5 läuft super.
Ja, Battlefield 5 ist ja auch gut optimiert mittlerweile.
Alles muss man sagen, Battlefield läuft immer gut.
Battlefield läuft immer gut.
Also Battlefield sieht immer optisch geil aus und es läuft immer gut.
Und vor allem scale Battlefield richtig gut.
Also sprich, wenn du Battlefield auf Low Details stellst, dann sieht das immer noch gut aus, aber es flutscht wie sonst was.
Neue Laberstellsvideos.
Ja, ich hoffe mal der Fabian spielt da mit.
Ich mache doch noch mal einen Ticken leiser hier.
Du könntest ja mal den Hersteller fragen in einem Forum, was der dazu sagt und du bist bestimmt nicht der Einzige, der Memory Leak Probleme bei dem Game hat.
Und was geht es gerade?
Wir basteln eine Gegensprechfunktion, also wir versuchen zumindest eine Gegensprechfunktion zu programmieren für meine China Camera Gegensprecheranlage, die ich mir gekauft habe.
Also Bild abgreifen.
Was ist mit der Kamera los?
Alter, was ist los?
Ich wollte sagen Bild abgreifen funktioniert schon mal wunderbar.
Alter, was geht?
Ok, ich starte die Kamera mal kurz neu.
Wo ist der Strom von der Kamera?
Wenn ihr sehen könnt, was ich hier für eine komische Konstruktion gebaut habe.
Ich habe einen 12 Volt Netzteil und da habe ich so einen Y-Split Kabel dran gemacht, was eigentlich für LED Streifen ist.
Und auf der einen Seite mein Access Point dran gestoppt und auf der anderen Seite die Kamera dran gestoppt und dann zwischen Access Point und Kamera ein Netzwerk Kabel.
Sieht voll abenteuerlich aus.
Die schicken gleichzeitig das ganze Bildmaterial an die Server in China.
Ja, das kann sein, dass sie das probieren.
Aber ich habe die Kamera, die hängt.
Man sieht ja hier die IP.
1134.11 ist ein komplett eigenes WLAN.
Da darf im Prinzip nichts raus.
Also aus dem WLAN darf nichts raus.
Und auch nur aus ganz speziellen Netzen darf da überhaupt was rein.
Das heißt die Kamera hat wirklich keine Chance irgendwas zu schicken.
Sieht man sich auf dem Chaos?
Ne, ne bin ich nicht.
Die Kamera, habt ihr es gehört?
Die Kamera knackt auch immer so komisch.
Also Evilness FPS, ich würde mal im Supportforum vom Hersteller fragen, ob da irgendwas bekannt ist.
Schickt ihr in die Kombination von TPU, Grafikkarte, Windows Version und guckt halt, dass du auch die neuste Windows Version installiert hast.
Also sprich zur Oktober Update.
Und dann fragt ihr mal, gibt es einen Link zur Kamera?
Ja, kannst du hier gucken.
Das ist eine von Hikvision, die habe ich für die Hälfte des Preises quasi abgegriffen.
Eine Hikvision DSK, allein schon der Produktname 8.1.1.2.i.m.
Hat nichts mit Instant Messaging zu tun oder vielleicht nach China oder versucht es.
Und sie sieht halt relativ hässlich aus, aber das Schöne ist, es ist halt eine komplette Gegensprechanlage.
Sprich du hast einen Klingelknopf, eine Kamera, einen Lichtsensor glaube ich und eine IR-LED für Nachtaufnahmen.
Und die hänge ich einfach draußen hin.
Und wenn dann einer klingelt, dann kann ich gucken, wer es ist.
Und dass ich mit dem Typ sprechen kann über die Anlage, müssen wir jetzt was programmieren, weil die offizielle App ist scheiße.
So, fangen wir mal an.
Ach, du hast denn schon eine Supportanfrage, ja mehr kannst du eigentlich nicht machen.
Wie gesagt, wir starten hier einfach mit einer Anwendung, die im Prinzip nur die Kamera ab.
Nach dem Neustart ist auch keine Bildfehler mehr drin.
Okay, auch nice.
Die greift nur das Bild von der Kamera ab.
Und ich habe auf der Kamera, wie gesagt, einen Aufkleber drauf, dass ich mich nicht...
Man sieht es hier, guck, wenn ich die Hand da vormache, also die funktioniert schon.
Dass ich mir die aus Versehen reveale.
So, machen wir mal aus. Im Hintergrund sieht man noch FFmpeg-Debug-Ausgaben.
Soll ich euch mal kurz zeigen, wie das FFmpeg-Abgreifen von der Kamera funktioniert?
Ich habe das zwar übernommen aus einer der letzten Streams, wo wir einen eigenen GIF-Decoder gebastelt haben.
Aber das Ding decode ich jetzt halt RTSP H.264.
Ich kann euch das ja mal kurz zeigen, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Also, das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert.
Das ist eine Windows-Form-Anwendung mit...
Wir haben es dieses Mal ohne DirectX gemacht, weil wir brauchen hier keine 1500 FPS.
Einfach eine Windows-Form mit einem Image-Element.
Und der wirft hier am Anfang den Decoder-Thread an.
Und hier in dieser Decoder-Klasse ist halt alles drin, was das Decoding von der Kamera macht.
Den startet man einfach mit der Uhr zum Stream.
Und dann decode das Ding halt so vor sich hin.
Hier in der Schleife.
Und schreibt das aktuelle Bild immer in diese Image-Box da rein.
Man sieht, das ist nicht viel.
Also, es ist mit FFmpeg relativ einfach, Video-Decoding-Geschichten zu machen.
Und FFmpeg ist auch relativ schnell, muss man sagen.
Das ist schon ganz ordentlich.
Und der Decoder funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Das hier oben können wir alles mal ignorieren.
Ups, war ich auf dem zweiten Bildschirm los.
Ne, keine Max-FPS gerade.
Das reicht.
Der Camera-Thread hat eh nur 30 FPS.
Und das geht mir über die Windows-Forms-Dinger allemal.
Bei der GIF-Animation, ja, da wollte ich 1800 FPS mit DiodeX.
Aber hier wollen wir das nicht.
Also im Prinzip ist das relativ kurz erklärt.
Hier kommt der FAD rein.
Das wird nicht verwendet, das ist noch ein Überbleibsel.
Noch ein Überbleibsel von unserem GIF-Decoder.
Kann ich eigentlich mal raus schmeißen.
FAD geht hier rein.
Dann macht er hier FFmpeg-Magic, so wie man FFmpeg halt initialisieren muss.
Das ist halt so, dass jedes Programm mit FFmpeg sieht gleich aus.
Ja, am Anfang.
Du musst irgendwie so einen komischen Kontext anlegen.
Dann sagst du dir Open Input.
Und da kommt der FAD zum Stream rein.
Dann durchsuche ich den Stream, was denn da eigentlich drin ist.
Dann nehme ich mir den ersten Stream raus.
Der erste Stream ist Video.
Der zweite Stream ist Audio.
Dann gucke ich mir rein, was ich für ein Kodak brauche.
Dann suche ich mir den Kodak raus zum Dekodieren von FFmpeg.
Dann erstelle ich irgendwie einen Kodak-Kontext.
Das Ding brauche ich, um das Bildformat umzuwandeln.
Also sprich, die Kamera, das ist irgendein anderes Pixel-Format, als Windows Forms anzeigen kann.
Und dann starte ich hier das Decoding.
Und der macht im Prinzip nichts anderes als eine Schleife,
in der er jeden einzelnen Frame vom Decoder liest.
Der liest den Frame von dem Stream, schickt ihn zum Decoder,
kriegt ihn vom Decoder wieder.
Und dann passt er noch das Format an und schreibt den Frame in diese Blocking Collection.
Und die lese ich dann von meiner Windows Forms Anwendung aus.
Aber da muss es gar nicht rumgehen.
Großartig, das funktioniert ja schon alles.
Jetzt probieren wir mal, dem Ding irgendwie Audio zu entlocken.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Und zwar...
Wie machen wir das denn jetzt am besten?
Genau, wir machen erstmal ein Button hin.
Einfach mit irgendeinem Button sowas wie hier...
Wie könnte man hier nochmal die Schrift ändern im Zeug?
Das war nicht so viel mit Windows Forms.
Wo ist es denn? Text? Name?
Ach da, Name Button 1 ist schon okay.
Ja, wo ist denn jetzt hier?
Ist denn jetzt hier der Text für...
Sehe ich es nicht? Ah, hier. Text. So, Play.
Nehmen wir das jetzt einfach mal.
So, und ich will jetzt, wenn ich da drauf klicke auf den Play Button,
dass der an der Kamera den Sound abspielt.
Und wie das funktioniert wissen wir prinzipiell,
nämlich weil wir das hier mitgeschnitten haben.
Das heißt, das hier bauen wir jetzt nach.
Und ich habe mal nachgeguckt, was die Kamera für ein Format braucht.
Das ist sehr abenteuerlich.
Also, wer mal in die Situation kommt, wissen möchte quasi,
er hat einen Link zu einem Stream und möchte wissen,
was da genau drinnen steckt.
Das ist relativ einfach mit FFmpeg.
Dann sagt man FFprobe.
Ja, das eine ist cool für die China Web Stock.
Jetzt genau, das machen wir jetzt.
Dann sagt man die Uhr vom Stream und FF...
Warum auch immer?
Warum braucht es Axis, wenn es das auch trotzdem machen kann?
Piss dich, Alde.
So, mit FFprobe kann man einfach gucken, was da drin steckt.
Und zwar, es steckt drin ein H264 Stream.
Das überrascht mich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Und das hier ist das Geilste.
Das Audio ist in einem vollkommen abgetreten Format.
Das ist quasi ein Format von 1900, keine Ahnung,
89 oder so für Telefone,
was die Chinesen hier verwenden zum Audioencoden.
Das ist wirklich antik.
Zeig mal, das ist wirklich uralt.
So, von 1900...
Ja, 1900...
Ja, 1984.
Also sprich, die Chinesen verwenden in ihrer Kamera
einen Codec von 1984.
Das muss man sich erst mal überlegen.
Das ist schon nice, oder?
Aber glücklicherweise kann man den Kram auch
im Jahr 2018 noch decoden.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man so einen uralt Codec verwendet.
Ich meine, man könnte einfach ein ganz normales AAC oder so
verwenden bei einem H264 Stream.
Aber ich glaube, das ist einfach zu 0815 zu Standard.
Das wollen die Chinesen in dem Fall nicht.
So, jetzt versuchen wir mal,
die China Websockets nachzubasteln.
Also, als Erstes... Ach ja, ich habe schon mal ein Audio vorbereitet,
was in diesem komischen Format ist.
Und zwar FF Probe Desktop Piano 3.
Ich habe es konvertiert.
Nicht?
Na, ist es doch.
Habe ich das denn hinkopiert?
Ah, da habe ich es hinkopiert, okay.
Ich habe nichts zum Waff-Abspielen registriert.
What?
Windows, was ist denn da los?
Oh mein...
Nee, sag mal, die Datei ist auch leer, oder?
Nee, nee, die Datei ist nicht leer.
Warum kann ich in keinem Waff-Abspielen?
Was ist denn mit Windows jetzt schon wieder los?
Okay, wisst ihr was? FF VLC.
Scheiß noch Windows VLC.
Desktop Piano.
Ein hochqualitativer Klavier-Testton.
So, und den versuchen wir jetzt mal auf der Kamera irgendwie abzuspielen.
Und von der Idee her geht das folgendermaßen.
Wir müssen eine HTTP-Anfrage an die Kamera schicken
mit diesem Schmodder hier drinnen.
Den kopieren wir uns jetzt einfach mal aus dem Mitschnitt.
Danach schickt uns die Kamera das hier als Antwort
und danach senden wir einfach hirnlos unser File.
Fertig.
Und mal gucken, ob das die Kamera abspielt.
Also ich habe letztens schon mal mit dem Curl versucht...
Habe ich den Curl hier drauf?
Also ich habe letztens schon mal mit dem Curl versucht einfach das Waff-File hinzuladen
zur Kamera an die richtige Uhr.
Das funktioniert leider nicht.
Das klappt nicht.
So, das heißt...
Ja, und in meinem naiven Ansatz habe ich gesagt,
wir können einfach einen Webclient verwenden und HTTP hochladen.
Geht aber nicht.
Wir müssen das wirklich von Hand machen.
Das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein TCP-Socket.
Und zwar...
Moment.
TCP-Socket.
Wie heißt das gerade?
Moment.
Ist das nicht so?
Ah nein, wir sind hier in.NET.
TCP-Client heißt das Ganze da.
Ja, okay.
So, das ist jetzt wirklich raw.
Komplett TCP übers Netzwerk.
Ohne irgendwas drum herum.
Und zwar Zieladresse können wir noch angeben.
Die IP von der Kamera.
Und der Port war, glaube ich, einfach 80.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal, was wir hier mitgeschnitten haben.
Copy.
Copieren uns das mal irgendwie hier hin.
So, das heißt, das müssen wir jetzt nachbauen.
Raw TCP ist nicht...
Das stimmt, da ist zumindest noch ein bisschen Socket-Abstraction drüber.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich raw.
Okay.
Das heißt, nachdem wir jetzt nicht einfach sagen können, wir machen ein HTTP-Get,
müssen wir den Mist wirklich...
Müssen wir den Mist wirklich selbst zusammenbauen.
So, also, das heißt, wir machen jetzt erst mal...
Wir basteln uns jetzt erst mal einen Header zusammen.
Nein, wir basteln uns jetzt erst mal einen HTTP-Header zusammen.
Würde ich sagen.
Wir basteln uns jetzt erst mal einen HTTP-Header zusammen.
Und zwar als erstes brauchen wir hier die Anfrage.
So.
Als nächstes brauchen wir...
Ging das überhaupt noch mal so?
Ja, ging so.
Als nächstes den Host.
Wir kopieren das einfach nur, was wir mitgeschnitten haben in dem China-Tool.
Danach irgendwie hat Visual Studio das zerrissen.
Danach kopiere ich mir noch mal von hier.
Dann brauchen wir irgendwie so einen super-special-geheimen chinesischen User-Agent,
den er mitschickt.
Danach brauchen wir...
Wir kopieren das einfach.
Wir bauen das jetzt einfach nach, was da so ist.
So.
Accept language, chinesisch.
Natürlich was sonst.
Ist ja klar.
Ähm...
Accept...
Was ist das für ein Characterset?
Was ist das?
Ist das...
Äh...
China?
Simplified Chinese Characters.
Aha.
Mal gucken, ob die ich da noch an...
Äh...
Das müssen wir gleich selbst machen.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht.
Keep Alive machen wir mal.
Das müssen wir mit Sicherheit setzen, sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Eigentlich braucht man Keep Alive nur bei HTTP 1.
Aber wahrscheinlich bauen sie es in China auch in 1.1.
Keine Ahnung.
Content length 0, was auch geil ist.
Content length 0.
Content.
Aber Hauptsache Content length 0.
Na gut, die missbrauchen das ja als Websockets light.
Das ist kein Wunder, dass die Content length...
Weil die wissen es ja in dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht.
So, Content type stream.
Okay, das stimmt zumindest schon mal.
Gut, haben wir unseren HTTP-Header zusammengebaut.
Ähm...
Ob der Server auch die E nimmt? Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eigentlich ziemlich egal, was man da hinschickt.
Aber ich mach das jetzt einfach mal so, wie das in der chinesischen Anwendung auch drin ist.
Ähm...
Gut, jetzt...
Wir öffnen erstmal meinen File.
File.
Nennen wir mal.
Bytes.
Oder nennen wir mal.
Audio.
Bytes.
War.
File.
Read all bytes.
Und wo hatte ich das jetzt liegen?
Auf dem Desktop irgendwo, ne?
Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Wo hab ich's liegen?
Desktop, ja.
Okay, also C, Doppelpunkt.
Users.
Gibt's eigentlich, kennt ihr in den Visual Studio Plugin, was Fahrtergänzungen macht?
Gibt's da irgendwas Schönes?
Das macht jeder nur nach 15 Editor, plus Visual Studio macht's irgendwie nicht.
Ähm...
Desktop.
Piano 3 Punkt Waff.
Jetzt gucken wir, ob das auch funktioniert.
VLC.
Ja, funktioniert.
Hängt die Musik?
Hörst du an, als hängt die Musik im Stream, ja.
Lol.
Okay, das sind die Bytes von meinem File.
So, also...
Oh, fuck, haben wir einen Wireshark?
Ah, wir haben einen Wireshark drauf.
Das schaut mal gut.
Kann man schon...
Das wird jetzt...
Das wird jetzt blöd, hier einen Wireshark auszuführen, weil ich uploade ja Streben nebenbei.
Na, probieren wir das erstmal so.
Aber wahrscheinlich müssen wir zwischendrin mal mitschneiden und gucken, was ich da so schicke und ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Okay, also, Socket.
Ähm...
Stream.
Also...
Die Tastatur, ja.
Ich kann ja schreiben.
Also, von der Idee her ist das folgendermaßen.
Ich bau jetzt, sag mal, eine rohe TCP-Verbindung auf.
Zu dieser IP auf Port 80.
Der macht im Prinzip nur Handshake.
Weißt du?
Richtig geilen Gangster.
Zack, irgendwie sowas.
Also, er macht seinen TCP-Handshake mit 1 und 2, 1, 6, 8, 1, 1, 34, Port 80.
Und, ähm...
Doch, ich kann mal mitschneidenfiltern.
Doch, doch, das geht.
Also, ich kann nachher mitschneidenfiltern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich in Wireshark Form mitschneidenfiltern kann.
Oder bei mitschneidenfiltern kann.
Du hast bei mir im Hintergrund geprabbelt.
Das war aus dem Stream.
Aus dem Chills der 24-7-Livestream war das.
So, ähm...
So, also wir haben jetzt hier unsere TCP-Verbindung.
Aufgemacht zur Kamera.
Ich versuche mal ein bisschen so ungefähr zu erklären, was ich mir bei der ganzen Sache denke.
Weil ich denke immer dran, wir müssen diesen nicht-standardisierten Schmodder hier nachbauen.
So, das heißt, wir haben jetzt die TCP-Verbindung dahin aufgebaut.
Jetzt, äh, lassen wir uns den Stream geben für den Socket, wo ich Dinge reinschreiben kann und lesen kann.
Das heißt, ich sage jetzt einfach Stream.
Stream.
Ähm...
Right.
Und da schreibe ich jetzt meinen Header rein.
Wobei, kann ich das überhaupt einfach so machen?
Ach nee.
Ich brauche einen Byte-Array.
Da muss ich jetzt einen Byte-Array draus machen, okay.
Funktion String to Byte.
Ja, aber ich brauche eine Funktion String-Array to Byte-Array.
Aber das können wir...
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal von der Logik an unseren Header nehmen.
Joinen.
Mit einem Newline dazwischen.
Nee, Quatsch. Warte mal, wie ging das in C Sharp nochmal?
Warte mal, plötzlich.
Wir machen das ganz anders.
Am Ende des Strings fehlt eh noch ein Control.
Das ist richtig.
Das stimmt.
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Sonst hätte es wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht funktioniert.
Catch, Return, Newline. Muss sein.
So.
Wie kann man das jetzt schön elegant machen?
Select.
Und dann sagen wir Encoding.
Warte mal, das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Es sieht wahrscheinlich nicht schön aus.
Also wahrscheinlich wird es andersherum besser.
Ja, genau Patrick.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung habe ich mir auch gerade gesagt.
Encoding.
Was mache ich denn da?
Das heißt, Encoding.
Ascii.
GetBytes.
So rum.
Wobei, das ist plötzlich, wir müssen den Krams erst ja noch mal joinen.
Nee, nee, das ist total durch die Brust ins Auge.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich einen Byte Array.
Mit, ähm.
Oder?
Ja.
Wir haben jetzt einen Byte Array mit Byte Array drinne.
Was natürlich auch blöd.
Jetzt bräuchte ich eigentlich sowas wie.
Nee, jetzt machen wir anders.
Das ist blöd.
Wir machen das, wir machen das old school.
StringBuilder.
Bam.
Header.
Append.
So ist das noch viel schöner.
Zack.
So.
Was mir, das ist jetzt das Eleganz, was mir gerade so eingefallen ist.
User Agent.
Benutzst du Linux?
Wenn ja, wofür?
Für Server.
Für Surfen.
Für alles außer Audio, Video und Spielen eigentlich.
Im Prinzip.
Guck mal mit drauf, ob ich mich irgendwie vercopy paste oder so.
Zack.
Und am Ende brauchen wir natürlich noch den da.
Gut.
So.
Und jetzt sagen wir.
Header to String.
Ich geb dir dick Header alter.
String.
Und das sagen wir jetzt können wir sagen.
Encoding.
Coding.
Ich kann heute echt nicht schreiben.
Encoding.
Get Bites.
Aber die Corsair Tastatur macht es mir auch echt nicht einfach.
Weil mit ihren Minitasten.
Das ist jetzt to real header ist das.
Eigentlich brauchen wir das nicht.
Wir können das anders machen.
Wir machen dann mal ne Funktion draus.
Extract.
Create-Header
Zack
ToString
Das ist bisschen übersichtlicher, deswegen das ganze Scheiß nehme ich weg, wir müssen uns gar nicht mehr damit beschäftigen
Und wie ich wette mit euch, wir müssen diesen Header noch ein paar Mal createn, ich will das nicht immer copy-pasten
Ähm
Passt das und jetzt nehmen wir den hier
Sagen eigentlich gleich hier zack, zack
Zack, so ist das doch schön, da brauchen wir auch the real header nicht mehr, so und jetzt schicken wir das an den Server
Du musst mal ein Spiel auf Linux probieren, hat sich inzwischen stark gebessert, ich weiß es gibt von Valve gibt es jetzt den
Diesen Winefork, ich habe gerade vergessen wie der hieß, diesen diesen Vulcan-Wrapper
Nee, diesen Diode X auch Vulcan-Wrapper und Winefork
Proton, genau, ok, stream, write, bam, wir schicken jetzt den Header ein
Headwards
Header, bam, als nächstes Offset 0, längs, Header
Hier fliegen die Header, ein Header nach dem anderen
So
Und jetzt lesen wir mal die Antwort, die uns die Kamera schickt
Ich überlege gerade, wie man das jetzt halbwegs elegant
Das lösen, dass ich nur die Antwort krieg
Wir könnten den Stream-Reader oder irgendwie sowas nehmen
Du kriegst sowieso nur die Antwort, da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher
Was soll auf dem Socken, ich mein, ich weiß es nicht, ich mein, da kann man sich hier nie sicher sein
Ich mein, es dürfte theoretisch diesen kompletten Traffic hier nicht geben
Ich mein, ok, in dem Mitschnitt ist jetzt nichts drin, aber
Weiß ja nicht
Wir können es ja mal probieren, Stream-Reader, Stream-Reader
So, wir lesen jetzt einfach nur mal die erste Zeile
Read-Line, und dann gucken wir mal, was da ausgegeben wird
Also, zack, play, unauthorized, aha, aha, Moment, ich muss noch Basic-Auth machen, lull
Ja, und auch eine Sache, die, also kann ich, ich wollte gerade sagen, eine Sache, die man mit dem Standard-HTTP-Kleid nicht gescheit machen kann
Ist Basic-Auth, da muss man ein bisschen um die Ecke machen, aber
Im Prinzip ist Basic-Auth eigentlich ganz einfach, aber ich kann mir immer nicht genau merken, wie es funktioniert
Das ist irgendwie Base64 encoded aus irgendwie so
Und da ist Base64 encoded
Und dann Auth davor
Ok, warte mal, Basic-Auth ging doch irgendwie so, Moment, wo habe ich es denn?
Man hat doch hier irgendwie gesagt jetzt, keine Ahnung, Header, append-Line, und dann musste man irgendwie sowas machen wie
Authorization, Basic, und hier das Base64 gedönnt hin, oder?
So, ok, das muss auf jeden Fall ein Doppelpunkt sein, weil es ein Header ist
Ja, oder? So war das, glaube ich
Doppel-Basic
Kleiner, groß, glaube ich, egal
Und an der Stelle jetzt halt Base64
Wie macht man denn die Scharpen an? Bitte schön den String zu Base64
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, muss ich nachgucken
Ähm
Wobei doch, ich weiß es, ich weiß es
Ich weiß es, du konntest, ähm
Converter?
Nee, Convert
Ja, genau, Base64 String
Byte Array?
Warum muss, warum, da machen sie einem aber echt das Leben jetzt schwer, oder?
Also müssen wir wieder machen, Encoding
Encoding, ich kann nicht schreiben
Get Bytes, vielleicht
Vielleicht kennt ihr eine einfache Variante, das würde mich echt interessieren, das ist so gerade das beste, was mir gerade einfällt
Admin
So, ne, und das ganze als Base64 war
Off, oder so
So, hä?
Meint ihr das funktioniert?
Ah, ich weiß warum
Moment, ich weiß warum
Da darf kein Doppel, da darf kein Leerzeichen dazwischen sein
Ha!
Bäm!
Habt ihr die Kamera, habt ihr gerade die Kamera knacksen hören?
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß
Ich weiß, ich weiß
Habt ihr die Kamera, habt ihr gerade die Kamera knacksen hören?
Moment, ich versuch das nochmal
Jetzt knackst du mich mal, sonst hab ich keinen Bock mehr
Poggers
Okay, also wir haben es schon mal geschafft, uns an der Kamera anzumelden
Ähm
Äh, hab ich irgendwelche Diskussionen im Chat gerade vergessen?
Übersehen?
Ja
Hast du schon den Song von Rammstein Sänger Till Lindemann gehört?
Nö
Wusst du gar nicht, dass die irgendwas Neues haben
Ich bin aber auch kein großer Rammstein Fan
Ich mag zwar Heavy Metal, aber Rammstein ist nicht meins
Rammstein
Lindemann plus Haftbefehl
Ernsthaft?
Okay, warum eigentlich nicht, ja?
Das glaube ich aber irgendwie nicht wirklich
Ernsthaft?
WTF, Ernsthaft?
Wo gibt es das zu hören?
Okay, das müssen wir uns
Das geben wir uns nachher als Belohnung noch
Falls ich mir belohne, dass es sein wird
Ähm
Äh, wenn wir jetzt
Wenn wir jetzt
Wenn wir hier was auf die Reihe gekriegt haben
Okay, also, wir haben jetzt auf
ganz ekelige Art und Weise an die China Cam
eine HTP Anfrage geschickt
Glaubst du nicht, dass das Toss Safe ist?
Warum? Wegen
nackter Haut? Oder wegen
gewissen Sprüchen?
Das ist auf YouTube, wenn es auf YouTube nicht gebannt ist, dann juckt das auf Twitch auch
keinen.
Der braucht wahrscheinlich wieder Geld.
Hat er nicht irgendwie eine Freundin, die nur halb so alt ist wie er?
Ich mein, in seinem Alter würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch, wenn ich die Gelegenheit so hätte,
würde ich das auch so machen.
Es gibt bestimmt schlechteres, ja, der Typ ist ja wahrscheinlich auch schon 60 oder so,
oder naja nicht, keine Ahnung wie alt er ist, aber er ist alt.
Okay, also was wir wahrscheinlich nicht machen können ist read to end, weil die Verbindung
nicht zu Ende ist.
Was ist eigentlich aus deinem Date geworden?
Wisst ihr was?
Ich mach mal kurz die, ich mach mal den, die Kameraverbindung hier raus.
Der muss, der muss kein Bild jedes Mal anzeigen von der Kamera.
Kann man irgendwie ein Platzhalterbild rein machen oder sowas?
Dann haben wir Pictures, Stream, jetzt zeigen wir uns die Katze an.
Warum ist die Katze da nicht drauf jetzt?
Warum, warum, oh.
Hä?
Wo, warum ist die Katze da jetzt nicht drauf?
Was soll das?
Versteht das jemand?
Warum, warum nicht?
Eigentlich hätte ich erwartet, dass hier die Katze drauf angezeigt wird, aber die
neid wollen nicht.
Was hab ich da was verkehrt gemacht?
Es wird auch hier nicht in der Vorschau angezeigt, das ist, das ist schon immer verdächtig.
Ach so, Moment, hier Image.
Warum gibt es Image und Initial Image?
Okay, keine Ahnung, weg, gut, so Katze am Start, ist viel besser als irgendwie Platzhalter.
Nee, read to end funktioniert nicht, weil der erwartet, bis das Stream zu Ende ist.
Das funktioniert nicht, aber eigentlich müssen wir auch nicht die komplette Response lesen.
Es reicht mir ehrlich gesagt, HTTP, okay, den Rest brauch ich nicht.
Äh, irgendwie spackt das gerade rum, kann das sein?
Warum spackt man das jetzt rum?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, weil ich das nicht richtig beende, oder so, das hängt
jetzt und wartet und timeoutet erst in einer halben Stunde, oder so.
Hick, vision, api, pdf, aha, Moment, was das für eine Adresse, kann ich das jetzt gefahrlos
aufmachen?
So, suchen wir mal hier nach, nein, tatsächlich, 2 audio channels, channel ID, ja, ups, open,
vielleicht sollten wir das am Anfang machen, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal open schicken
und wir sollten auf jeden Fall einen Close schicken, wir schicken am Anfang einen Close,
dann closen wir alles, was noch offen ist, wir schicken am Anfang einen Close und am
Ende schicken wir den Close, so machen wir das, so machen wir das, dann funktioniert
das, so, ID, ID ist 1, ne, ID ist, ja, ID ist 1, was programmierst du, ich programmier,
für meine billig China Cam versuche ich die Gegensprechfunktion zu verwenden, also sprich
für das von dem Ding, das geht nur mit der offiziellen App, oder, also quasi China Websockets,
ja, das stimmt schon, ich zeig's dir gleich, und die Sache ist die, dass es entweder nur
über den ActiveX Browser Plugin geht, oder über die China App, und ich hab mal mitgeschnitten,
was das ActiveX Browser Plugin macht in der VM, und es ist absolut nicht HTTP konform,
sie verwenden's bei HTTP, aber sie machen so ein Zwischending zwischen HTTP und Raw
Socket-Gedöns, ganz merkwürdig, das versuchen wir jetzt mal nachzubauen gerade, so, äh,
das muss, Request, übergeben wir das jetzt mal halt hier an der Stelle, wir machen das
jetzt richtig, warte mal, hier, Moment, hier muss der rein, Request, das kann man alles
noch schöner machen, ich will jetzt bloß mal, dass es halt geht, und nicht ganz so hässlich
ist, so, das heißt, als erstes schicken wir, bevor wir irgendwas anderes machen, schicken
wir einen Close dahin, Close, und dann hoffe ich, dass es wieder funktioniert, Close, Stream
Right, gucken wir uns mal die Response an, ob das jetzt funktioniert, Moment, muss es
ein Put sein, oder muss es ein Get sein, es muss ein None sein, wat, Alter, China Dokumente
ey, ja, was muss es denn jetzt sein, Get, Put, Put, ah, steht doch da, Put, Put muss
es sein, ok, gut, fuck, das hängt, das hängt, ich glaube ich muss die Kamera mal neu starten,
wir probieren mal was anderes, versuchen wir es mal hier, ah, ok, Curl, auf die Kamera,
80, und jetzt, Admin, super krasses Passwort, Invalid Operation, warum, bin ich jetzt blöd,
warum ist es, ah, Moment, ich muss die Methode noch angeben, Put, oh, das hängt irgendwie,
ich glaube ich muss die Kamera mal neu starten, ich hab's irgendwie kaputt gemacht, so, Moment,
mal neu starten, kacke, ja, das kann schon mal passieren, ja, bei sowas, also wir können
ja von der Theorie her weitermachen, so, also als erstes schicken wir den Close für alles
was noch offen ist, am Ende können wir leider nicht nochmal nen Close schicken, weil sie
immer noch hängt, wir schicken am Anfang nen Close, doch am Ende können wir auch nen
Close schicken, warum, Moment, nee, wir schicken das einfach gar nicht, wir schicken das nicht
im, wir schicken das überhaupt nicht im Socket mit, das machen wir gar nicht, wir schicken
einfach vorher, wir machen noch nen Harddp Client, so, Eats, wir schicken das einfach
so hin, bevor wir mit dem ganzen Schmodder anfangen, machen wir einfach ne ganz normale
so, so, so wie man das offiziell mit.NET macht, Put, kann das nicht, kann das nicht
Sync putten oder so, nein, wir sind ja in.NET, wir müssen, also, wir müssen ja alles awaiten,
okay, Put, Moment, hab ich überhaupt das Richtige, ich muss doch gucken, ob die Kamera
wieder da ist, okay, Kamera ist wieder da, den Schmodder machen wir wieder weg, den machen
wir wieder weg, okay, Put, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie Harddp Client funktioniert, ich nehm jetzt
Upclient, das ist der alte, so, und da sagen wir jetzt, Upload Data, und zwar wir Uploaden
keine Data, wir schicken einfach nur nen, dahin, oh, da müssen wir jetzt wieder Basic
Auth vorher machen, wobei, nee, nee, nee, müssen wir nicht, das Ding kann sowas hier,
das ist ja ein bisschen advanceder, irgendwie setzt man den Krempel nochmal, irgendwie,
wie war das, Network Credentials oder so, ja, genau, Admin, so, und jetzt schicken wir
das hier, genau, dahin, da machen, den Request machen wir jetzt, bevor wir mit irgendwas anfangen,
zack, als Method, nehmen wir Put und Data, ja, brauchen wir nicht, kann man da anstatt
Upload, was könnte man da sonst nehmen, Upload String gab's doch, ja, so, und jetzt sollte
der eigentlich jedes Mal, so, und das machen wir am Ende auch noch, wenn wir fertig sind,
das waren wir am Anfang, das waren wir am Anfang, und wenn wir fertig sind, machen wir
das auch nochmal, dass der Krempel auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall dicht ist, Basic Auth
noch drin, stimmt, ja, so, sehr schön, HTTP, okay, nice, gut, jetzt kann der Kram auch
immer hängen bleiben, okay, weiter geht's, jetzt müssen wir, also wir wissen schonmal,
das funktioniert, da machen wir jetzt einfach Stream, nein doch, das lassen wir mal, wir
lassen uns das okay hier ausgeben, so, und jetzt Uploaden wir, Copy, ich weiß halt nicht,
ob das funktioniert, Open Read, da holen wir uns ein Stream vom File und, Moment, umgedreht
muss ich's machen, Audio Copy to Stream, so, mal gucken, ob das jetzt eigentlich, ich glaube
ja nicht, dass es funktioniert, mal gucken, es kann sein, dass uns jetzt gleich die Ohren
wegfliegen von der Kamera, ne, Kamera hat geknackst, oh, habt ihr's gehört, die hat
was gemacht, oh, hört ihr das, ich halte euch mal dran, macht ihr nichts mehr, also,
ich glaube, man hat's ein bisschen gehört, und ich glaube, ich weiß auch, woran das liegt,
und zwar, aber das Schöne ist, dass überhaupt was rauskommt, das ist schonmal ganz toll,
da hatte ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Schiss vor, weil das hat mit Curl überhaupt nicht
richtig funktioniert, und ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt, ich hab mir nämlich
den Traffic schonmal ein bisschen angeguckt, mir ist immer gerade eingefallen, wenn man
sich das hier anguckt, die Dinger sind alle ganz kurz hier, guckt, also, das hier ist
irgendwie, nehmen wir mal sowas, hier pushen die ja irgendwelche Daten rauf, ne, so, das
ist hier so ein, so ein, so ein, von der offiziellen, wie gesagt, von dem Mitschnitt, von der App,
die pushen das in ganz kleinen Häppchen da hoch, also immer in 214 Bits, wobei, ne, sind
weniger, in 160 Bits pushen die das da hoch, das heißt, wir können, und was wir gerade
machen ist, wir uploaden alles in einen Push, ne, also, ne, so ein Standardpaket, was passt
da rein, irgendwie 1500 Bits oder sowas, also in ziemlich großen Happen schieben wir
das da, schieben wir das, den Audio Stream da hoch, das heißt, wir müssen das in kleinen
Häppchen machen, deswegen gehen wir aber wieder rückwärts, so, und jetzt sagen wir, also
jetzt versuchen wir den Krempel mal in kleinen Häppchen da hoch zu laden, also, Wild 2 ist
immer, kann man ja fast nichts falsch machen, ok, Wild 2, und jetzt, das ist eben, was heißt
es, um es bei Wild 2 in Z Werbung aufzuladen, also, also, wir machen letztens etwas, die
Das hab ich in dem Projekt schon drinne. Das ist übelst nice für alle C-Sharp Programmers unter uns.
Hab ich was gefunden, das nennt sich, ähm...
More Link.
Und damit kann man so Dinger machen wie...
Das passt mal auf, das ist echt nice.
Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich schnell sein, aber das ist wirklich praktisch.
Damit kann man sagen, Audio Bites, Batch...
War das Batch?
War ziemlich sicher, Batch.
Batch.
Okay. Using More Link.
So.
Okay, nochmal von vorne. Damit kann man nämlich...
Batch. Ja, jetzt funktioniert's.
Damit kann man die Dinger nämlich Splitten in Häppchen.
Das heißt, ich sag, ich nehme jetzt mal ein Byte Array.
Und splitte mir das mal bitte in 160 Byte Häppchen.
Das ist übelst nice. Das geht auch.
Du kannst das Groupen und Selecten und so.
Aber das ist viel schöner.
Das spart einem ein bisschen Getippe.
So, und jetzt machen wir nämlich ne Schleife.
Und jetzt haben wir hier immer 160 Byte Häppchen.
Ähm...
Zum Uploaden.
Stream.
Riot.
More Link ist aber echt geil.
Das ist wirklich sehr nice.
Stream. Riot.
Item.
Ähm...
Offset.
Item. Leng...
Ach so. Ja.
Das ist kein...
Ich muss erst mal in den Array umwandeln.
Bytes.
LoL.
Length. So, mal gucken, was die Kamera jetzt macht.
Äh, äh, Tomika.
Also, die haben richtig viele coole Sachen in diesem More Link drin.
Ich hab bei weit noch nicht alles mir angeguckt.
Ich hab das auch erst vor ein, zwei Wochen gefunden.
Aber das ist echt nice.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Man muss halt dazu sagen, Link ist generell nicht das schnellste.
Also, wenn es super Performance braucht,
dann ist so ne nackische Schleife immer noch das beste.
Aber es ist wirklich...
Das sieht doch auch hübsch aus, ne?
So, mal gucken, was die Kamera jetzt macht.
Macht überhaupt was?
Die macht gar nichts mehr jetzt.
Oh, doch, doch.
Hört mal, sie macht wieder das Gleiche.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, ähm...
Tja.
Threat. Sleep.
Scheiß drauf.
Sleep, 50 Millisekunden.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Oh, oh, oh!
Habt ihr's gehört?
Krasser Scheiß.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch rausfinden,
in welchem Intervall wir das schicken dürfen.
Da hat es nicht abgeangt.
Okay, vielleicht waren wir immer noch zu schnell.
Waren wir 100?
Bäh, das ist noch schlimmer, oder?
Also...
Also, es gibt...
Das ist nämlich so richtig gut.
Okay, dann sind wir...
Dann waren wir immer kürzer.
50 hatten wir 25.
Hä?
Oh.
Bäh.
Warum kann ich jetzt nicht doppelt da draufklicken?
Das müssen wir uns alles noch mal in Ruhe angucken.
Close.
Aber...
Hört noch mal hin, es ist fast...
Es ist fast gut.
Ich weiss, wir können ja auch mal versuchen,
logisch dran zu gehen.
Das ist so ein Audio-Format.
So, das ist ein 800 Hz-Ding.
So, Bitrate...
Also, von der...
Logischen Zeichen aussehen.
Das Ding hat eine Bitrate
von 64 Kilo...
Sind das jetzt Kilo Bit oder Kilo Byte?
Na, Kilo Bit.
Müssen das sein.
64 Kilo Byte.
Wäre ein bisschen viel.
Das wäre ja ISDN.
Und wir haben gelesen, das ist ein Kodak von 1984.
Da hat kein Mensch an ISDN gedacht.
Ja, das sind Bit, glaube ich auch.
Also, 64 Bit.
Das sind 8 Byte.
Oder?
8 mal 8.
Nee, was?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Irgendwie bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass 8 Byte richtig sind.
Warum sind 8 Byte richtig?
8, ne?
Okay.
Das heißt...
8000.
8000 Bytes pro Sekunde.
Ich muss die Streams früher machen.
Ich kann abends überhaupt nicht mehr richtig denken.
Das bedeutet doch jetzt,
wenn ich 8000 Bytes die Sekunde habe,
8000 Bytes die Sekunde habe.
Okay.
8000 Bytes pro Sekunde.
Bytes pro Sekunde.
Dann muss ich...
So.
Okay.
160 Bytes pro Paket.
8000 durch 160 sind 50.
50.
Also muss ich 50 Mal in der Sekunde diese Schleife durchlaufen lassen, oder?
Also 50 Mal pro Sekunde.
So.
Und 1 durch 50 sind 20 Millisekunden.
20.
Ich glaube, mit ausprobieren wären wir schneller hingekommen.
Aber jetzt haben wir die Logik, ja?
Sollen wir mal gucken, wie das jetzt ist.
Es kann aber sein, dass wir es ein bisschen schneller machen müssen,
dass es nicht buffert, oder das buffern kann, oder was weiß ich.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Oh.
Warum kackt das eigentlich ab, wenn ich es nochmal ausführe?
Was hat das für Probleme?
Moment.
Warum kackt das ab, wenn ich es zweimal ausführe?
Hört sich gut an, ne?
Hört sich gut an.
Aber warum kackt das ab?
Hä?
Jetzt kackt es nicht mehr ab.
Jetzt hängt es.
Ah, jetzt kackt es ab.
Jetzt hängt es. Ah, jetzt kackt es ab.
Unable to write data to transport connection.
Okay, ah, ich weiß warum.
Ich vermute mal, weil ich versuche,
von der gleichen Anwendung zum gleichen...
Wobei das eigentlich egal ist.
Was weiß ich? Scheiß drauf.
Es spielt den Sound ab, die Kamera.
Das ist doch schon mal geil.
Ah, sehr nice.
Ja, ein Close.
Hier ein Close ist natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Da ist was dran.
Ein Close ist nicht verkehrt.
Hier ein Close.
Wir könnten auch einfach einen Using-Trom herum machen, ne?
Man könnte theoretisch auch einfach einen Using-Trom machen.
Das wäre die schönere C-Sharp-Variante.
So, gucken wir mal.
Ja, okay, parallel geht nicht.
Doch, doch.
Das funktioniert.
Ich meine, dass GUI hängt,
weil ich das alles im GUI-Smart mache.
Also, so wie das nicht war.
Wie schiebst du die Zeilen hoch und runter?
Alt und Pfeiltasten geht das.
Guck mal. Funktioniert.
Ich klicke jetzt ein paar Mal.
Das kackt nicht mehr ab.
Und...
Er macht das jetzt halt mit ordentlichem Lack.
Ich klicke jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, ich muss das mal abbrechen.
Sehr schön.
Sehr nice, das funktioniert schon mal.
50 auf 1 Sekunde, easy.
Wir sollten jetzt vielleicht mal anfangen,
da einen eigenen Thread für zu bauen,
weil das ein GUI-Thread ist.
Boah, kotzen.
Wollen wir mal eine eigene Klasse führen?
Ah, das ist...
Das ist... Wie nennen wir das Ding?
Lol, Audio.
China!
China Audio.
Das ist das Ding jetzt, super.
Ja, das hat keine Akte, auf die ich auch gerade gekämpft habe.
China Thread.
Okay.
Ähm...
Äh...
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Halt, ich bin verwirrt.
Genau, hab ich nicht installiert.
Ähm...
Public...
Start...
So, und jetzt brauchen wir
irgendwie sowas wie, ähm...
Task...
TF.
Äh...
Ist gleich, ähm...
Task Run...
Boah, nee, das machen wir nicht inline.
Private...
Avoid...
Wir nennen es einfach
als Decode.
Es ist zwar nicht, nee, es ist nicht Decode, es ist, es ist...
Es heißt Run!
Fertig, es heißt einfach nur Run.
Das ist, da muss man sich nichts überlegen.
So, das startet jetzt die Methode
Run.
Oder wir nennen es, kommen wir nennen es
Work. Work.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Ach so, ähm...
Ja, das ist ja, das haben sie mit der nächsten Donate-Version
gefixt, da muss man den Kram nochmal karten.
Casten...
Boah, so, ja.
Okay, und wenn man
hier Start sagt, dann...
Was hat er hier
für Schmerzen mit?
Read Only, ja, kann man machen.
Wenn man ein Private davor, gut ist.
So, Start...
Task...
Start...
So, mehr müssen wir nicht machen. China Audio.
Das heißt, wir lagern das jetzt mal ein bisschen aus.
Das China Audio Zeug.
Weil, das wird sehr unübersichtlich
sonst.
Okay, ähm...
Was wir auf jeden Fall machen,
ist das hier am Anfang.
Immer. Am Anfang von jedem
China Audio, machen wir die alte China Audio
Verbindung zu.
Weil, man weiß ja nie.
Das heißt, das ist absolut nicht
Multithread
tauglich zu dieser Kamera, in dem
Fall. Wenn ich es immer
close. Aber mein Two-Bay-Audio
geht ja logischerweise auch immer nur zu einem
Endgerät. Und das
Neues bricht es halt ab.
Ja, da kann man
eh nichts machen. Das ist also im Prinzip
okay.
So, und den ganzen Schmodder
kopieren wir jetzt rüber.
China Audio
Zack.
Ja, alles importieren.
Äh, meine CreateHeader
Methode brauchen wir auch noch.
Zack.
Okay, gut.
Tp-Client.
Hat er jetzt
für Schmerzen? Ach so!
Äh.
So, ha.
Passt das jetzt?
Ja, MoreLink
müssen wir ein...
MoreLink
Extensions, zack.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir das ein bisschen
ordentlicher gemacht. Das ist in der eigenen
Klasse.
Wat?
Ach so! Ha! Ich hab die!
Ups.
So.
Äh, warum ich kein Partner bin, weil ich einfach
den anderen noch nicht gestellt hab? Immer noch nicht!
Ich hab ja eigentlich gesagt, ich mach das im Dezember, aber
ja, ihr kennt mich ja noch.
Bei so was bin ich immer
nicht der Schnellste.
Dezember ist noch lang
stimmend. Ich kann das immer noch machen.
Äh, wir
brauchen noch ne...
Wir brauchen noch ne Stopp-Methode, würde ich sagen,
ne?
Stopp.
Wobei, eigentlich, eigentlich
brauchen wir das, brauchen wir das nicht.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen eigentlich nur ne Start-Methode.
Wir brauchen eigentlich nur
eigentlich brauchen wir nur ne Start-Methode.
China Audio.
So.
Reich, New,
China Audio.
Das heißt, in unserem Klick
können wir jetzt einfach sagen,
China Audio
Start.
So,
wenn ich das dann öfters ausführe, sollte es abgebrochen
werden, oder?
Fuck.
Ah!
Moment. Äh, ja klar.
Das funktioniert nicht. Ich brauch doch ne Stopp-Methode.
Ich brauch doch ne Stopp-Methode.
Und dann, und dann, und dann wird's
gar nicht mehr so einfach jetzt. Bäh, das ist scheiße.
Das hab ich was
ekliches gemacht jetzt.
Ähm, weil
ich brauch hier immer die Möglichkeit abzubrechen.
Das ist natürlich
äh,
probieren wir das mal.
Cancellation
Cancellation Token Source.
Das war ein bisschen Multi-Swerding-Gedöns.
Token Source.
Das ist,
so möchte Microsoft, dass man das macht.
Sachen, die man abbrech-
bar machen kann, zum abbrechen.
Ich mein, wenn das Ding hängt,
dann hängt's hier drinnen.
Das heißt, wir gucken jetzt einfach hier.
If
Cancellation
Token Source
Ähm,
Token
Is Cancellation Requested?
Dann sagen wir Break.
So.
Und hier drinnen
sagen wir dann
This Cancellation
Token Source Cancel.
Zack, Stopp.
So, und jetzt sollte das eigentlich
sich-
Moment, äh,
ich mach das ja auch vollkommen falsch.
Ich will das nicht runnen lassen.
Ähm,
ich will das- Moment, Moment, Moment,
ähm,
aber wie ging das nochmal
in Task anlegen?
Der, der nicht
gestartet ist, ähm,
Create? Nee, äh, äh,
oder einfach New- New- Task?
So ging das, ne?
Ja, ich hab das- Blödsinn,
was ich hier gemacht hab grade.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Hä?
Warte mal, ich bin grad
irgendwie echt-
Ach so.
Hallo, L-Shorks.
Stopp ist nicht blocking, ne?
So, aber jetzt,
jetzt-
Das wird jetzt noch nicht funktionieren.
Genau, so, äh,
ich stopp.
Also wir stoppen das erstmal.
Moment, das ist, das ist eh vollkommen Blödsinn,
was ich hier mache. Das da muss
hier weg. Ähm,
und
das muss nach Stopp hin.
So.
Da kann ich auch nicht mehr
Read-Only machen.
Also wir haben ja mehrere Tasks. Wenn wir Stopp-Start
machen, ähm,
Stopp-Start.
So, und jetzt muss ich noch sagen,
This-Task-Wait.
Weil Wait ist immer irgendwie
hässlich, aber in dem Fall
bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig. An irgendeiner Stelle
muss man mal warten.
Wat?
Moment.
Äh.
Ach so.
Ja, Moment, ich, ich, ich stopp,
ich stoppe jetzt, ja.
So. Ha, verarscht.
Aha.
Sehr schön.
Aber, aber
die Kamera macht nichts mehr? Warum macht die Kamera
nichts?
Alter, ist das ein Akt.
Tasks, Stopp.
Stopp, Tasks,
Tasks-Start.
Warum, warum
spielt jetzt nichts ab?
Fieback.
Bist doch einschneidend.
Ja,
ja,
ja.
Hä?
Ah, ich weiß warum.
Oh, bin ich blöd?
Ja, weil ich hier oben einmal gesagt cancel,
und das ist immer gecancelt danach.
Also muss ich
im Prinzip auch noch,
also muss ich hier im Prinzip
sagen so was ja so und jetzt muss der kram auch funktionieren
ha ha funktioniert guckt leute
funst nice kann man eigentlich sowas das ding ancanceln das geht nicht
das geht nicht die die möchten dass man einen neuen einen neuen token immer
generiert
mach im start einfach task ran aber dann kann ich doch hier nicht oder doch
kann ich stimmt kann ich machen so und ich muss doch eigentlich auch gar nicht
warten oder muss ich warten eigentlich nicht doch ich muss weil wenn ich nicht
wenn ich im stopp nicht warte dann habe ich hier wieder das problem dass es
mehrfach den gleichen kram macht
mehr es gibt bestimmt 1000 varianten wie man das schöner machen kann aber es
geht mir hauptsächlich um das audio von der kamera so also wir haben es jetzt
raus also wir haben wir können zur kamera was uploaden abspielen das doch
schon mal gut so das heißt ja als nächstes brauchen wir den umgekehrten
weg und zwar sound sound abspielen von der kamera würde ich mal so sehen ok
das heißt wir brauchen wir brauchen mehrere tasks wir brauchen auf jeden fall
ein thread oder ein task für das uploaden von sprache und wir brauchen
ein thread für das downloaden von sound das können wir schlecht
es muss sich unbedingt noch ein thread sein es muss zumindest darf nicht blocken
also haben sie sowas wie also nehmen wir das ding einfach mal kein upload upload
hast und dann machen wir ein ein download task windows forms ab 10 ja besser
name ok das heißt wir müssen den ganzen schmatter den ich hier gemacht habe bis
auf das bis auf das start und stopp bis auf das start und stopp müssen wir
jetzt doppelt machen wobei halt nicht ganz also es sind schon zwei
unterschiedliche sachen aber das haben wir so das docket anlegen und sowas
von außen kommt zu an die kamera garantiert keiner dran
es reißt die einer von der wand ab wenn ich sie unten dann an die wand machen aber
aber deswegen muss ja sagen das geht nicht so einfach weil es ist ja eine
wandal resistant doorbell ist nicht einfach nur ein doorbell und die ist wirklich stabil also das
ding ist massiv ja und auch die schrauben wie das wie das an die wand kommt das reißt man nicht so
einfach ab ok das heißt wir machen jetzt mehr socket close wir machen jetzt mal das extra
helme in der methode und das nennen wir es war hier start so gut guck mal kontrolliert
mal alles funktioniert also ich nupt ich mache jetzt ja um ran ok nice was wir
noch auf jeden fall machen sollten ist wenn wir hier prägen wobei machen wir machen wir machen
socket close wenn wir prägen das ist ok das ist ok so das heißt wir machen jetzt eine
methode start download start download und da versuchen wir jetzt mal audio abzurufen von
der kamera oder es wird eklig wir müssen es hier irgendwie in windows wiedergehen wie machen wir
das am besten also ja mit in audio das habe ich sogar schon titel geschrieben aber das ist ja
dieses kack format scheiße das wird ja viel komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt
habe das ist ja dieses das ist ja dieses komische kack format was die kamera hier liefert dieses
von 1984 das ist das ist ein audio format aus meinem geburtsjahr stell euch mal vor so was
verbauen im jahr 2018 ok wir brauchen auf jeden fall wieder in socket vielleicht gibt es paar so
ich vermute mal in audio kann das wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwie konvertieren das klappt schon
das klappt schon das kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin aber es wird wahrscheinlich kompliziert es
ist ja auch es ist im prinzip auch nur es ist nicht encoded also das ist das ist alles
es ist halt bloß so ein so ein so ein so ein waff auf sparflamme quasi pcm auf sparflamme
somit meint man sogar das hat das hat eine abtast frequenz oder wie man das genau von
8000 herz es ist halt nur für sprache gut für nix anderes das hört man also das klavier gespiele
hat wirklich schlecht an das weiß ich wie gut das hier rüber kommt das klingt wirklich scheiße
ja ein channel und ja das ist das vielleicht vielleicht können die das auch so direkt abspielen
das probieren wir mal ok also mal denken wir brauchen es hier ok start download so und da
ok wir machen jetzt hier einen neuen socket auf und jetzt müssen wir mal wieder rüber
switchen auf unser hauptsinn windows ausgemacht auf unsere windows vm wo ich das mal den den
weihrauch laufen habe hallo windows ok wenn er es möchte neu gestartet werden auch gut
starten wir noch neu warten bis neu gestartet ist ok wir machen wir machen das ganz genauso
wir machen das wir machen das exakt genauso plus das wird sein get get sagen das weiß
das habe ich im weihrauch gesehen wir machen jetzt get auf die uhr und und jetzt sagen
wir jetzt jetzt sagen wir ja genau den header wieder und danach lesen wir einfach lesen
wir einfach nur noch ach so ja das stream soll ich auch mal aufmachen das ist vm aber
das ist alles vm ja das ist alles vm ja also jetzt sagen wir im prinzip eigentlich nur
noch read ich würde vorschlagen wir reden wir reden auch oder mest hat gerade eine twitter
nachricht geschrieben er kriegt sein er kriegt sein enteuer tablet nicht geroutet ja ich
habe gesagt das können kann ich mit ihm zusammen machen ok weiter im text also wir lesen jetzt
vom stream ich würde sagen wir lesen auch einfach 160 byte immer 160 byte lesen und
ich will jetzt und ich printe den kram jetzt einfach auf die konsole weil ich gucken will
ob das prinzipiell tut was was was wir hier machen also sprich ob ich dann halt auch die
antwort krieg also stream reads wir lesen ok wir brauchen ein buffer mit 160 da kommt
ihr für sie scharf kommt es einem richtig vor so so so weit schieben rein zu machen
das macht man ja eigentlich relativ selten und in zukunft wird das ganze noch viel einfacher
weil die haben irgendwie so eine neue klasse habe ich gesehen in einem in dem video die
haben irgendwie sowas wie die span und und memory und so was das ist quasi so ein bisschen
so abstraction da oben drüber offset null buffer längst mal gucken ob das so funktioniert
was ich was ich hier fabriziere wir gucken einfach mal wir geben einfach mal den buffer
aus encoding ascii get string wir gucken mal da müsste jetzt ja auch der header drin stehen
der header müsste drin stehen und danach einfach nur noch bullshit danach einfach nur aus
sound von da von der kamera ok start da ok mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert warum
macht er nichts macht er doch oder auch nicht was was genau macht er da
ich bin verwirrt was was ja tommy habe ich gesehen das ist so geil das ist so geil dass
jetzt diese dass du quasi ranges und sowas drinne hast das ist man weiß eigentlich gar
nicht wie sehr einem das gefehlt hat bis man jetzt wieder sieht dass es kommt das ist
wirklich das ist das super super geschichte sie haben ein paar coole sachen drinne ich
habe ja ich habe ja die ganzen videos geguckt die hatten ja letztens irgendwie connect davor
dort netcon davor in so bild man muss ja sagen microsoft legt bei allen ihren produkten jetzt
mal unabhängig von windows das ist halt immer noch windows aber so ihre entwickler sachen
ein unglaubliches tempo vorne ok ich mache noch mal ein sleep hier auch mal zwanzig ich
habe keine ahnung was der hier eigentlich gerade macht wir machen mal wir machen was
anderes counter ich gebe jetzt einfach mal aus was er treibt keine ahnung was macht
er da warum läuft das überhaupt nicht parallel ach so ich noob alter bin ich blöd ich bin
total bescheuert ich moment mal das ist total und ich dachte was ich hier mache ich darf
jetzt nicht starten sondern ich muss ich muss upload starten start hier upload das muss
ich upload start upload muss ich muss ich lauschen so und jetzt download task muss ich start
download muss ich das jetzt auch parallel läuft aber total beknackt mal original studio
19 angeguckt ich habe einen ich habe einen webcast angefangen diese auf der connect ausgestrahlt
haben aber noch nicht komplett ok warte mal was bau was was ich hier mache ist total blödsinn
ich starte überhaupt nicht hier drin ich mache das in berg so ist das gut weil es
wird danach auch immer noch wenn das immer noch nen moment blödsinn das muss ich anders
machen dass das am ende schicken das am ende schicken muss ich anders machen weil das würde
jetzt ja immer ausgeführt werden da muss ich was anderes überlegen ok mal gucken ob
das ob das audio gekrabe jetzt funktioniert ja nee
ich sollte doch da nicht immer den header raus kriegen oder
sprinte mal keine bites in die konsole dann sehe ich aber nicht was er macht also der
header sollte da definitiv nicht immer kommen
da kommt jetzt bite array bite array moment da müsste aber noch da müsste noch mehr
mehr schwuppeln kommen bin ich ok wisst ihr was wir müssen uns noch
unser mitschnitt angucken wir müssen aber den mitschnitt angucken wie das mit dem get
funktioniert hat ich habe ich weiß dass ich irgendwo gespeichert habe da so putt putt
uns das get da unauthorized get da ja prinzipiell geht das so wie ich das gemacht habe
es schenkt nach vorne
Also ich wundere mich jetzt, es müsste eigentlich so funktionieren.
Jetzt müsste ich mal selbst Wiresharken und gucken was er macht.
Gucken ob das der rechner ja ja remind me later er ist er nicht eins
okay ben capture stopp spielst du eigentlich was zur zeit ah nicht wirklich ich habe jetzt
angefangen habe ich mir schon vor ewig auf steam gekauft kingdom come deliverance übelst
nice mittelalter game also eines der wenigen wo wo die spitzern gesehen habe wo das mittelalter
auch wirklich so aussieht wie das mittelalter ok protokoll sortieren wir mal nach hat b das
ist mein live stream live stream pizdich wo ist der tp moment
meinem gett stimmt was nicht das gett gettet nicht richtig oder gettet das geht doch richtig
schauen doch doch das gett gettet richtig wie hast du die windows suche so gut was moment
meine windows suche ist doch genau ist doch übelster crap oder was meinst du die hier
ne welche denn die hier die verwende ich doch gar nicht die ist dies übelste müll dies
wirklich müll guck mal vlc findet er zum beispiel nicht wer findet vlc nicht mehr richtig seit
dem letzten update obwohl vlc installiert ist ja warum warum geht das nicht richtig
ich habe bestimmt einen ganz groben logikfehler irgendwie
ist stream 1 korrekt ja es gibt nur den es gibt nur den jaja das stimmt schon vermute ich mal
das oder ist oder ist es irgendwie eine rein folgegeschichte statt upload
hier widerspricht sich auch nichts drin oder
das macht er vor allem anderen ich bin jetzt grad irgendwie ein bisschen verwirrt wie man
wie man das hat er denn für schmerzen warum geht das nicht ich mache doch genau das was die was
das was die china software auch macht
null null ist er nicht richtig
ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen langsamer ja
komisch also das funktioniert so nicht
ja kann das an der content length liegen
ich mein content length null ist ja ok es ist ja auch null
ich finde es echt
ich bin jetzt echt für mehr tun so hat er da seine probleme
den dampf ja hier oder da ist halt nichts doch der macht den socke zu warum warum
macht er meinen socke zu das ist die falsche der macht meinen socke zu
ja
sagt ok dann macht er aus irgendwelchen gründen auch mal einen sinn
weiß ich so genau warum den china dampf
der china dampf sieht folgendermaßen aus da macht in get kriegt ok zurück
und dann datenzeug also ich habe noch eine idee ich habe eine idee man kann man kann ich glaube
das müssen wir machen ich glaube man muss dem setzen dass er nicht blockt
aber das kann man auf jeden fall mal setzen
schadet auf jeden fall nix noch irgendwelche komischen sachen im header
guck mal maschinen dampf gibt alive ich kopiere es mal rüber
ist im prinzip das gleiche get audio data host basic aus user agent except except language
den mist brauche ich das da vielleicht nicht weil ich nicht glaube dass das irgendwas
ändert an wobei content type application octa stream immer noch am besten ist eigentlich
ok wir gucken wir gucken noch mal diese komische api doko von den dreien weil die haben wir
die haben wir nämlich noch so ein open drinnen das machen wir jetzt einfach mal wir machen
jetzt hier noch ein open davor ganz am anfang noch ein open
ha ha lul china kacke das ist komplett unlogisch warum geht in der upload oder den open aber
der download geht nicht das ist komplett unlogischer scheiß das ist komplett unlogischer crap
das ist komplett komplett jeglicher logik
china china kram meine güte ok nice sehr schön fons fons gut ok muss immer stehen geblieben
ja ist das stream read blablabla result
hallo kanto bite ah ja ok ok ok wir haben das also es passt doch eigentlich passt doch eigentlich
das ist die
Ich habe N-Audio schon ein paar mal verwendet, das ist allerdings schon ein bisschen her.
Ich muss mal nachgucken, wie das richtig funktioniert.
Ich habe irgendwo noch was.
Warte mal, ich durchsuche mal mein Kram.
N-Audio.
Ich finde nichts mehr.
Doch, ein Folder.
Das bringt mir aber nichts.
Ah nein, ich habe etwas gefunden.
Was mache ich denn da?
Da spiele ich eine Datei ab, das bringt mir jetzt allerdings nicht so wirklich.
Was ich in dem anderen Projekt gefunden habe, ist folgendes.
Output-Device-Wave-Out.
Das ist dann das erste Win.
Ich hoffe, uns bläst jetzt nicht gleich die Ohren weg.
Wann kommen neue Videos?
Ja, Output-Device.
Das habe ich hier eingestellt und dann habe ich gesagt Output-Device-Init.
Hier habe ich eine Datei, hier kann man eine Datei reinhauen.
Ich will ja keine Datei abspielen, ich will ja quasi einen Stream abspielen.
N-Audio-Play-Stream.
Play-Audio-From-A-Stream.
How-To-Playback-MP3.
Da ist einfach nur Code drin.
N-Audio-From-Stack-Overflow-Driven sind wir heute wieder richtig.
N-Audio-Craft-RP.
Was ist das?
Das ist Microsoft.
Geh mal fort.
Buffered-Wave-Provider.
Ah.
Ja, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Man sagt dann hier quasi sowas wie, ähm.
Out-Wave-Format.
Ja, da müsste ich jetzt den Mist angeben, der hier drinne steht, ne?
Was es ist?
Also
Format
Waveformat
Waveformat, so und was hatten wir da? Wir hatten eins. Sample Rat ach nee doch oder nee
Ja in 8000 stand da stand was von 8000 channels eins
So Format
Read, read, read
Add
Okay
Hier sagen wir den buffer kommt da rein den will ich abspielen
Und hier drinne sage ich dann
Add Samples
Und zwar den Buffer ich habe bei mir heißt gerade alles Buffer Buff in Buffer Buff Format out
Nee
Das was wir geredet haben das muss da rein
Wie heißt eigentlich das Unternehmen was der arbeit ist das verrat ich nicht so 20 Sekunden
20 Millisekunden
Also leute es kann sein dass uns jetzt die Ohren wegfliegen play
Ich werde das so schnell wie es geht wieder beenden falls uns die Ohren wegfliegen aber
Self-Documenting
Oh war das laut das
Sound ist weg
Also angeblich war das relativ laut
Okay, das ist das falsche Format was der hier abspielt das das stimmt hier nicht das stimmt nicht
In audio
Mula to decode Mula das brauche
Er macht da
Ich
Stakeoverfloor, sag ich doch, immer Stakeoverfloor, Stakeoverfloor, FDW.
Create a lore, custom, mool lore, was auch immer ey, okay 8000 und eins.
Warum genau ist das so irgendwie so ein static Ding und man kann das nicht bei new einfach
angeben, so is mool lore, oder irgendwie, oder, oder, ach was weiß ich, es ist immer
immer schwierig so extra Würste da abzufackeln.
Man hätte ja ein Waveformat machen können und ein mool lore Waveformat auch noch, aber
so ist es eigentlich auch okay, okay Achtung, Alarm, könnt sein, dass die Ohren wieder
wegfliegen.
Schonmal besser, oh man hört mich, geil, oh es ist abgekackt, es ist abgekackt, aber
das hat prinzipiell funktioniert, habt ihrs gehört, es ging, es ging, also prinzipiell
ging es, prinzipiell ging es, guck mal, ich zeig es euch nochmal, dass es prinzipiell
ging, Achtung, es kackt immer ab, warum kackt es ab, da stimmt was mit meinem gebuffere
das stimmt hier nicht, buff out, warte mal, ich muss mal abgucken, discord und overflow,
brauche ich bestimmt, so und buff out, da kann man nämlich noch einstellen, ich kann
das schreiben, out, buffer length, so, warte, nee, das ist time, ah ich finde es da, duration,
time span, so, time span, der buffer soll reichen für das format, soll reichen für
0 stunden, 0 minuten und 2 sekunden, alles was länger dauert als 2 sekunden ist eh
für ein arsch, 2 sekunden, wenn wir 2 sekunden brauchen mit der Türgegensprechanlage zu
reden bis dahin ist der dhl-dude schon längst wieder weg, is read only, ok, ah buffer duration,
wir haben 2 way audio ja, aber es kackt nur ab, moment es geht immer kaputt, wenn, moment
es geht kaputt, wenn das hier fertig ist, warum, ich close das doch gar nicht, ah, wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich, oh man das ist so obskurer china kack eh, wahrscheinlich wenn ich den
upload channel zumache, dann denkt er auch es ist quasi close, also lassen wir mal einfach
alle sockets auf, also es stimmt auch bei unserem format fast noch nicht, das wars,
jetzt wird er abgekackt, kackding, warum kackt denn das ab, warum kackst du ab,
außer dass es komische geräusche macht, wobei, jetzt ist er abgekackt, komm einfach so,
zwischendurch kackt es einfach ab, weiß nicht warum, warum kackt es zwischendurch ab, das
gibt ja überhaupt keinen sinn, das andere, der andere stream ist schon längst fertig,
doch der socket wird garbage collected, der socket wird garbage collected und dann, dann
gehts zu, thread sleep, boah das wird richtig eklig jetzt, so, jetzt sleept er mal eine halbe
stunde oder so, achja und wir machen mal die sleepzeit ein bisschen geringer, weil das
gibt komische geräusche, bla, bla, bla, test, test, test, bla, bla, bla, nein, warum kackt
der scheiß ab, china kacke ey, was ist denn das, liegt vielleicht am dotnet framework,
ne, das glaub ich nicht, ha, warum kackt das ab, ok, leute, wireshark teilt, ok, ok, ok,
time, wireshark, ha, ich habs, ich habs drauf auf jeden fall, what, ah, ok, ne ich muss
noch mal neu capturen, ich brauchs von anfang an, ok, jetzt wird er abgekackt, oh, wireshark
time, also, atdp, warum kackt das ab, putt, das ist wirklich sagen, wo ich glücklicher
geschnippt hab hier, oder auch nicht, was macht der da zwischendrin, ist das der versucht
die sache nach china zu schicken wieder, finn, also nicht der mesh sondern das dcp flag,
also der typ sagt mir einfach die gegensprecherlage sagt mir einfach, verbindung fertig, warum,
warum, dafuck, moment die pakete hier sind größer, ha, hier sind die pakete 320 bytes,
ich hab gott, china, klar, oh mann, das overflowet wahrscheinlich, irgendwie sowas vermute ich
jetzt einfach mal, ich bin wahrscheinlich nicht, nicht schnell genug oder so, ach, keine
Ich habe was geiles gefunden gerade ich gucke nämlich gerade vom anderen Bildschirm nach
vor anderen code wir machen das jetzt anders wir machen das jetzt gucken ob das funktioniert
buffer buffer ich blick nicht mehr durch bei mir heißt alles buffer aktuell buffer result buffer
das ist upload download da sind wir buffer buffer alles weg ne das brauchen wir format
brauchen wir format brauchen wir rave out brauchen wir auch so und jetzt brauchen wir
einen einen rostream zwar einen rostream dem kann man jetzt nämlich den stream einfach
übergeben vom audio und das format und dann macht er das für einen dieses ganze buffer
geliebe und vielleicht riede ich ja einfach nur den buffer falsch wie auch immer man den
buffer falsch wie ich so und dann copy paste muss man das drunter machen dass er dass er
weiter weiter läuft ok gucken ob er jetzt abkackt ach nee bei mir heißt es nicht rave
out sondern die weiß output die weiß ok so test test test test test test geste noch geste noch
scheiß ding alter warum kackt es ab richtig riesel gibt überhaupt kein sinn dass es abkackt
es gibt überhaupt kein sinn warte mal liegt das vielleicht dann ne ne das liegt nicht
an mir der hat jetzt er sagt ja der server sagt ja vorbei ist schluss ist ich sag ja
eigentlich nur audio start sonst nichts ich sag hier nirgendswo stop ja jetzt bin ich
echt ja ist immer anders liegen könnte dass das ding automatisch wenn irgendwie kein
dass es solange wenn kein sound reinkommt dass das ding also sprich wenn wenn es kein
input mehr bekommt dass es dann zu macht einfach als da meinung ist es irgendwie vorbei
oder so das heißt wir schreiben da jetzt einfach null nullen rein wenn wir fertig sind wir
schreiben das einfach nullen rein schreibe einfach nullen rein fertig ich brauche erst
mal ein buffer mit nullen kennt jemand eine schöne schöne sache ins die scharfe ein buffer
mit nullen zu initialisieren außer halt eine vorschleife gibt es da irgendwas schönes
also ok ne moment mit nullen ne mit nullen ist es standardmäßig wahrscheinlich schon
oder wahrscheinlich muss ich für nullen gar nichts machen das ist sind einfach schon immer
immer nullen das ist so lauter für graben damit beschäftigt man sich normalerweise gar
nicht ok ich hoffe dass man sich mal ein ohrwerk fliegt funktioniert es läuft weiter es läuft
weiter man muss einfach nullen rein schreiben easy test nice läuft weiter einfach nullen
rein schreiben pock alter pock ist das hässlich hier ok also die lösung das ist es ist wirklich
so wenn du china geräte quasi anspricht musst du selbst china programmieren dass es funktioniert
es klappt es einfach nicht ich mein warum warum muss ich jetzt hier einfach permanent nullen
reinschreiben warum kann das nicht einfach so weiter funktionieren pogas sehr schön
so das funktioniert doch eigentlich das was wir vorgestellt haben so jetzt eine sache müssen
zwar noch machen wir müssten jetzt irgendwie das wird jetzt jetzt wird es eklig also was wir
jetzt ja aktuell schaffen ist sound von der kamera abzurufen und auszugeben das ist ja eine sache und
wir schaffen einen feil was schon im richtigen format ist schaffen wir abzuspielen die sache ist
ich will ja dem ich will einem typ an der tür kein klavier vorspielen man der denkt vielleicht
wäre es nicht schlecht stellt euch mal vor dhl klingelt und dann macht es dann warum nicht aber
eigentlich mit der doppelt eigentlich sollte es ja bei dhl nicht piano spielen sondern sollte
mich hören das heißt ich muss jetzt noch irgendwie gucken mein mikrofon capture mit audio
hörst du denn auch was wenn du nur sendest klar das haben wir eben ausprobieren funktioniert
so das heißt ich muss jetzt mein mikrofon irgendwie capturen und das in dieses komische
format umwandeln und dann an die kamera schicken boah scheiße wie machen wir das denn ok also das
heißt start upload wir wir machen jetzt ok erst mal erst mal muss hier mal spicken wie man mit
audio mit audio mikrofon capture das habe ich hier nämlich auch irgendwo drinnen hier ja das
ist total simpel nice so also dieses bites ersetzen wir jetzt mal durch mein mikrofon
die weiß null ist wahrscheinlich die folgt ich würde ich werde mir damals schon was bei
gedacht haben way format nehmen wir das was am nix dran ist zu dem mist was wir abspielen
müssen wobei ich probiere mal mal ich probiere mal ob man ob man direkt das in diesem komischen
format aber das kann das kann wir noch nicht kann mir nicht vorstellen bzw. mein mikro kann
es nicht glaube nicht dass mich wenn aus in diesem komischen format die korn lässt aber
probieren wir mal aus da darf da darf kein links da oder doch lässt es mich doch aufnehmen
ok ane man muss noch sagen start recording dann kackt es bestimmt ab
lässt mich wenn aus in diesem komischen format ernsthaft aufnehmen
ach moment ich sehe jetzt die exception nicht richtig weil die hier in dem thread ist ne
ja ne das geht bestimmt nicht in dem format also wave in machen wir hier das normale gibt
die kamera irgendwas aus wenn die nullen senders wenn das piano fertig ist
nö wahrscheinlich nicht also ich höre zumindest nix es rauscht leicht aber ganz leise
ich muss ja auf jeden fall nullen senden weil das ding möchte ja quasi 8000 bytes in der
sekunde möchte das ja haben sonst funktioniert sie irgendwie nicht sonst macht sonst macht
ja die in den lautsprecher zu also man muss man muss nur in senden ok start recording so und jetzt
konnte man sagen das ist eklig was ich hier mache jetzt kann man sagen data available dann
kriegt man wenn das mikrofon was aufgenommen hat kriegt man was so wenn das mikrofon aufgenommen
hat kriegt man was so und zwar kriegt man hier buffer man kriegt beides recorded probieren wir
jetzt aus also wenn ich jetzt laba sollte jetzt hier was kommen bla bla ja ok das nimmt auf
mal mikro so und jetzt muss ich diese sachen irgendwie in die kamera bekommen kann ich nicht
einfach kann ich einfach sagen kann wir probieren das mal aus was passiert wenn
ich wenn ich einfach raum eine daten nehme und an die kamera pushe das probieren wir mal aus
also e buffer e und dann beides recorded so als könnten jetzt könnten wir gleich die
ohren wegfliegen jetzt könnte man gleich die ohren wegfliegen je nachdem was man macht ok
das ist keine gute idee glaube ich glaube das ist keine gute idee weiß ich ob das gehört
habt aber wahrscheinlich das ist nicht das funktioniert auf jeden fall so nicht ok das
heißt das müssen wir in irgendeinem aber das schreibe jetzt auch in so den komischen buffer
von n audio rein buffer in new bufferts wavestream oder wie das so hieß das format
ja so ne ne das sollte ja schon das sollte ja schon das tagel format sein 8000 ein channel
sondern schreiben wir das hierhin ne oder hat man ich bin ich bin verwirrt gerade
wir schreiben das erstmal da rein also das wird jetzt wieder eklig klingen gleich aber
ich will nur mal sehen ob das jetzt an sich funktioniert count recorded bytes
so und hier
jetzt nicht mehr die datei haben sondern jetzt brauchen wir endlich brauche ich ja auch
unsere endlose schleife wird ja wird ja wird ja zeit also wie es lieben wieder 20 sekunden 20
senden können wir uns jetzt sparen so und jetzt uploaden wir den kram einfach aus dem
buffer von 160 so und da lesen wir jetzt was da lesen wir jetzt die bytes raus und dann
schreiben wir zur kamera ob das was wird das klingt ja auf jeden fall wieder eklig
stream right da schreibe jetzt den buffer rein was ein rum buffer geschiebe hier das klingt
wahrscheinlich auch wieder eklig was das so und jetzt kommt der moment
wo wir in den sauren apfel beißen müssen irgendwie den shit den wir aufnehmen vom
mikrofon in in in das da zu konvertieren ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
der overflow fragen wir jetzt einfach in audio das erste erste suche ist das schon moment
umgedreht ob wir gucken wir wie die das hier machen
das braucht man nicht wir brauchen das umgedrehte das gibt es doch bestimmt auch
oder teufel ist am start so also vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein encoder
wie heißt das ding
la decoder encoder bm nice linear tun nur der sample so der will den short der will
den short short sind so bald bald ist klar weil es in acht also nicht bald achte was
ist in den short 16 bit ja 16 das machen soll ich das machen ok das ist auf jeden fall die
funktion die wir brauchen das ok also jetzt jetzt big brain big brain brauchen wir jetzt
jetzt war wirklich massive massive brain und zwar was bastelst du gerade ich versuche ich
habe mir so eine billig china kamera gekauft für 80 euro und das ist eine kamera mit
gegensprechfunktion und die gegensprechfunktion funktioniert nur mit der offiziellen app oder
im active browser plugin und es wir kriegen es ja schon hin also wir kriegen es hin bisher
mit was selbst gebautem den das audio von der kamera abzugreifen und auch schon hin
dass die kameraden einen feil abspielt was ich jetzt probiere ist gerade dass mein mikrofon
gelaber da müssen wir übrigens aufpassen dass wenn zurückkopplung gibt mein mikrofon
gelaber dass das an der kamera ankommt ok also wir brauchen auf jeden fall eine schleife
und zwar eine schleife über mein input buffer und das machen wir nicht hier das machen wir
nicht hier sondern hier hier müssen wir den kram konvertieren das heißt wir verwenden
jetzt mal wieder schöne schöne link expression also buffer batch in zweier plöcken weil
wir müssen jetzt ja irgendwie ich hab keine ich kann euch die internen internen sachen
hier von diesem format nicht erklären aber wir müssen quasi 16 bit wenn encoded zu
einem byte also 16 bit werden zu 8 bit das heißt wir brauchen das brauchen immer zwei
bytes und die stecken wir den encoder oder kriegen wir ein byte raus soweit die theorie
des ganzen jetzt ok aber man schleifert rum weits moment das habe ich schon oder das hieß
schon irgendwas bei mir meine variablen namen sind gerade alle ganz toll wenn was als doppelt
hast du schon ein geschenk für das krönbachs erinnere mich nicht daran ich langsam sehr
langsam wird es echt ernst so jetzt muss ich echt was holen jetzt oder noch amazon auf
den letzten drücker bestellen also nee ich habe noch nichts
ja das ist eine frage aber ich bastel beantwortet ok jetzt ok wir nehmen jetzt diesen komischen
encoder hier short sample ich vermute mal dass ich vermute mal dass man sowas hier nicht
machen kann oder result ist immer die beste variablen namens jetzt sind wir gleich wir
nennen es nicht result wir nennen es kombined weil es ist ja quasi die bytes ja ich weiß
dass 21 der ist der klein von amazon außer außer express express geht glaube ich bis
22 oder so bis 23 ok also die old school variante wir machen jetzt die old school variante die
old school variante ist bitch shifting also ich mein ziel ist jetzt ja das nennen wir
übrigens nicht kombined das ist total bescheuert anahme dafür machen das anders wir machen
hier um was es immer kommt weil so und jetzt brauchen wir das soll dann short werden also
16 also das heißt wir brauchen jetzt auf abit das ist übelst hier im verbiegen immer ok
also wir müssen es um acht schiften irgendwie und das andere nach rechts oder das kann ich
mir nie aus dem kopf merken zumal es ist die scharf auch ein bisschen anders es habe ich
so in ganz entfernt im kopf als bc zum beispiel wenn man bits irgendwie schiff also also wir
nehmen jetzt wir nehmen jetzt keine wir fangen hinten an so das zweite byte und wir machen es
jetzt anders first bites second ich muss es jetzt ein bisschen sprechen machen weil ich
check sonst nicht also er geht ja nicht also ist das hier first spoilt mich mal nicht falls
ihr es wisst nicht nicht backseat programmen muss jetzt mal selbst drauf kommen so falls
jetzt falls ihr es wisst so also wir nehmen jetzt also mein naiva ansatz wäre ja mal wir
nehmen first schieben das irgendwie um acht nach ne nach links ok wir müssen es auf jeden fall wir
müssen es auf jeden fall danach als shortkasten sonst mag der uns nett ok also wir schiffen wir
schiffen das nach links also das bedeutet wir haben ja so oh man ich macht aber ein punkt
dazwischen immer buffieren bei einem nippel nennt man das 4 4 bit nippel ok wenn ich das jetzt wenn
ich das erste jetzt acht nach links schifte dann habe ich das hier drinne stehen oder ich das ist
wohl das mache ich so selten so was dann habe ich das hier drinne stehen so wenn ich das jetzt
und ich glaube einfach mit dem mit dem zweiten moment ich mache das falsch rum ich mache das
falsch rum ich mache das falsch rum weil das hier muss second sein weil das zweite weit muss weiter
vorne sein weil das weil das signifikanter ist also ich muss das second muss das second das zweite
weit muss ich acht bit nach links schiften dann haben wir es dann hier drinne stehen da haben wir
dann hier irgendwie sowas stehen so keine ahnung so das hier ist immer noch 00 und wenn ich das
jetzt unde mit dem ersten dann funktioniert das dann geht das ne nicht oder muss ich ich muss
es oder ich muss es oder weil wenn ich das unde dann dann kommt was anderes raus weil also das
zweite das zweite ist ja dann im endeffekt sowas hier quasi vertauscht sowas hier wenn
ich das jetzt wenn ich das jetzt oder wenn ich das unde dann kommt wieder patrick sagt
null raus ja aber wenn ich das oder die scheiß wort was wenn ich das wenn ich das oder das hat
ein parfüm oder programmierer deo oder so und dann kriege ich das raus ich könnte ich
könnte aber auch x oren oder es kommt in dem fall auf gleiche raus weil hier immer nur nullen
stehen ich glaube das wird in dem fall auf gleiche herauskommen oder und x oren mit dem
hütchen sieht natürlich immer geiler aus als einfach nur dann oder also das müsste funktionieren
ich habe ja noch so gewissen rest zweifel dass es dass es tatsächlich klappt aber zumindest
mein geschichte müsste funktionieren ich gucke jetzt mal stack overflow was sie dazu
schreiben bevor wir uns gleich das ohr wegblasen sie schabt bald zu short converting to bald
zu short richtig mit converter jetzt ja langweilig das ist das kann ja jeder das kann ja jeder
irgendwie eine komische klasse aufrufen oder nix gut
komm mal hier was macht der denn da
der macht im prinzip das gleiche ne plus ja ja das macht im prinzip das gleiche das hier
ist dann quasi acht mal eine null und die zahl addiert plus acht acht bits der wert
und nullen das ist das gleiche in dem fall das ist das gleiche zu dem was ich mache
ja das ist doch viel schöner so so ok ok so da entkommen wir jetzt die kombinen beides
und bekommen ein result und zwar wir bekommen ein bald als result das bedeutet wir müssen
uns die beides irgendwie ich will es nicht wieder beides nennen kein output wir haben
ja besten variablen namen ever output ist ein ein eine baldliste oder so bist du dir
sicher dass das minus minus vor dem oder ausgeführt wird nicht minus minus dass das schiff
das ist eine gute frage sie schaab operator präsent genau mal gucken schiff ist vor oder
es müsste funktionieren ob es wirklich funktionieren sie immer gleich schrift ist vor dem ich
bin aber die schönere variante wäre auf jeden fall so na ok jetzt nehmen wir den output und
adden das bald rein so und danach nehmen wir den buffer
danach nehmen wir den
das ist doch eklig das ist ein error
so das ist nicht beides rekord das ist beides rekordet durch zwei oder und was machen wir
wenn beides rekordet dann fehlt was wenn beides rekordet ungerade ist wobei beides rekordet
darf nicht ungerade sein sonst kann ich sonst funktioniert es wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig
ja na doch dann hat er hier null hat er hier null im letzten bald oder so null fast jeder
kackt an der stelle ab weil es kein last gibt wahrscheinlich ach was weiß ich wir probieren
es jetzt einfach mal so aus ok achtung ok moment ich bin verwirrt was genau erwarten
wir eigentlich jetzt genau dass das mal mein gelaber in der kamera hört hallo alter das
funst hört ihr krasser scheiß das hätte ich nicht gedacht das hätte ich echt nicht
gedacht wirklich nicht also ich hätte gedacht uns fliegen jetzt die ohren weg oder oder
uns platzter kopf irgendwas aber nicht dass es geht ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es funktioniert
ich bin ich bin übelst perplex so jetzt mache ich mal das das video wieder platt
platt das video wieder ein jetzt haben wir eigentlich eine halbwegs funktionsfähige
gegensprechanlage zwar sehr rudimentär das ganze und wir haben bild von der kamera guck
mal play button da unten der ist halt ein bisschen nicht sonderlich responsive platziert
so guck mal wir haben kamerabild und wir haben sprachverbindung perfekt
kenne funks keine ahnung weil es weil mir das gerade so eingefallen ist wahrscheinlich
ist das wirklich nicht schön ist eigentlich lisp bei das kann man schon schöner machen
lisp bei weil wir weil das der output ist der output ist ja in beidt der output ist
beides das hier mit sys muss hier in beides rein
Also optimal ist das nicht
Aber es funktioniert das einzige was mir jetzt noch auffällt bis ein bisschen merkwürdig ist hört mal hin wenn man es startet
das das knackst das knackst sowohl beim hier im im höre als auch an der kamera
man könnte das absicht das macht er mit der offiziellen app nicht
ne ne ne ne das macht er nicht nein das macht es nicht wenn es mit der gegensprechanlage vom
hersteller macht nein das ist kein feature und ich zeig es euch wir machen das jetzt mit der
software vom hersteller knackst nämlich nicht alles ist das ding schon wieder windows please
nice dass über 110 leute dienstags abends am start nicht dienstags sonnabends abends am start
bei einem gegensprechanlagen proga stream es gibt aber bestimmt interessanteres auf twitch zu
gucken aber ich finde es schön dass ihr alle dabei seid
baust du auch eine wagenschleife musik ein ich glaube nicht dass man das braucht für den dhl
mann guck wir machen jetzt mal dieses ekliche direct x active x front end auf von der kamera
wenn ich da auf das mikrofon drücke dann guck macht es nix
also ja geht nicht also knack nicht und ich finde es auch ein bisschen doof dass es knackst
ehrlich gesagt hast du die cam abgeklebt ja klar uns gibt es ja noch unbeabsichtigen reveal
ich finde das eher ich finde das eher cool so viele leute zu gucken bei proga streams ich
weiß noch so die die letzte zeit wo ich also vor december wo ich paar wochen wirklich viel
gestreamt habe da hatten wir teilweise an die 300 zuschauer bei bei was war das denn
bei kickstarter projekten gucken oder irgendwas in der richtung und ich finde es auch immer
interessant zu sehen da steigt immer also wenn man also eins ist auf twitch wirklich fast noch
wichtiger als auf youtube eigentlich dass man regelmäßig streamt halbwegs regelmäßig ja
eins zweimal die woche reichen sollte regelmäßig sein aber dann sieht das immer dass die leute
immer erst so ein paar tage vielleicht auch der eine oder andere eine woche braucht bis
er quasi wieder mitgekriegt hat dass man am start ist also das auf twitch wirklich wichtig
ich weiß woran das liegt wisst ihr was ich glaube wo habe ich nie mein mein mein upload
code upload code download code upload code download code muss ich und bei nähe
ich muss in den
download ist das wo ich den sound abrufe das ist egal upload
und zwar ich glaube das liegt
wie viel kostet dann eine lizenz für fremder 80 euro oder so das aber nicht die aktuellste
version ich habe keine lizenz für die aktuellste version player ist kostenlos ja wobei denn
nene der player ist doch der player ist immer noch kostenlos aber übelst versteckt
es gibt schon 50 glaube ich habe noch vor einmal 13 ja das ist natürlich das nächste
es ist wie mit allem im internet das meiste muss man sich nicht kaufen wenn man nicht
wirklich will es gibt immer verschiedene varianten aber ich will hier keine keine
waritz geschichten anpreisen im stream oder so dann ist monka tos angesagt unter stream
weg was kostet denn aktuell offiziell die fremder seite ist so hässlich geworden die
fremder seite war ja schon war ja noch nie schön aber mittlerweile ist die genauso hässlich
und unübersichtlich wie manche andere seite die ausgeburt des bösen ist immer noch die
fremder die die ibm seite bei abgelten was kostet mich das abgelten von 13 geht geht
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich muss abgelten auf 14 machen und abgelten auf 5 ok es wird
einfach schon mal die helfe der seite geploggt auch auch sehr nice alles irgendwie das gar
maßdinger hallo wenn wir vielleicht möchte ich geld geben darf ich darf ich euch geld
geben bitte nein darfst du nicht die neid ok man darf es bei fein wenn ich mehr raus
bekommen was es kostet amazon gibt es bei amazon zu kaufen ernsthaft ah ne ne das workstation
12 das ist alt kaufen die fremder seite gerade einfach im arsch kann das sein machen wir
wieder an ich kann euch nicht sagen was kostet so also wie gesagt ich glaube ich weiß woran
das liegt und zwar dass es also ich weiß warum es im download knackt und das liegt
daran also warum warum es beim starten von dem mikrofon knackt weiß ich nicht so genau
aber hier im kopfhörer knackt es weil weil guckt mal wir haben den ganzen header noch
nicht gelesen wir versuchen den wir versuchen den htp header als wachdatei abzuspielen
was natürlich komisches also wenn ihr wissen wollt wie sich eine wachdatei wie sich nen
htp header als audio anhört dann hört man genau hin so hört sich htp header an
weil guckt mal wir wir machen die anfrage was genau soll hier heute eigentlich passieren
ist ist schon was passiert wir haben eine gegensprechanlage für meine für meine kamera
gebastelt guck mal ich zeig's dir also doppelt jetzt weil obs und kamera wenn ich jetzt hier
schnippe und livebild das haben wir heute gemacht und jetzt versuche ich gerade noch
das knacken ein bisschen rauszukriegen also wir müssen jetzt erstmal den header richtig
lesen weil wir spielen den header aktuell ab als audio und das ist mit sicherheit nicht
sinn und zweck der sache deswegen haben wir wieder unseren freund die endlosschleife weil
er nicht genau weiß wie lang der header ist und wir machen ein stream was machen wir denn
jetzt lasst mal überlegen wie kriege ich jetzt raus wann der htp header vorbei ist
also er ist vorbei wenn karatsche turn line feed kommt aber wie mache ich denn das jetzt
am besten wie scanne ich das denn jetzt am besten ja lesen bis dass ist das ich weiß
ich überlege gerade wie ich das programmieren richtig weil die stream readers können das
nicht die sind nicht so sophisticated dass ich sagen kann retou oder sowas einfach bald
mit endvergleichen das reicht ja allein noch nicht weil es ist ja nicht jeder zeile zeilen
änderung also ich meine ich könnte ich könnte bei lesen wenn es new line ist lese ich das
nächste bald wenn es nicht ich lese das bein wenn es backslash er ist dann lese ich das
nächste bald nach korea backslash ennis und also quasi stream read byte so if es gleich
so aus in der richtung oder
sowas ja würdest gerne auch sowas content bei hunipop würde auch gern so ein content
tutorials von dir auf youtube sie aber das kann ich bei mir nicht machen auf dem channel
das ist für 99 prozent der leute oder so bei mir ein bisschen mehr 95 prozent der leute
ist das nicht interessant oder das übersteigt auch so ein bisschen die pc skills der normalen
user und das ist ja auch nicht schlimm sie jeder programmieren kann das kann ich aber
nicht bringen ende sollte kontrol ja ja logisch weil jedes jede zeile müsst ihr eigentlich
sonst so enten also so im prinzip prinzip so break zentlose endlose schleif es hat wirklich
sehr angesagt wie es aussieht es knackt nicht aber ich höre mich noch gut ok das hat funktioniert
es knackt nicht mehr der htp herr ist weg wir haben halt natürlich wieder so geile endlose
schleife am start hier wenn der herr mal nicht so ist ok und jetzt gucken wir uns noch mal
an was denn die china software macht warum genau sind hier x an den programm dran warum
sind die warum sind hier x dran dass die china hacker haben die sich von der kamera aus in
meine windows vg hacksorten haben x an meiner algen gemacht warum die x her jede jede verknüpfung
jede verknüpfung hat ein x übrigens ich bin verwirrt ich bin gar nicht in der vm ich
bin mit der freund starten neustart neu startet bei windows immer wir brauchen die windows
vm die hier nämlich genauso aus bis auf die eikens auf dem desktop so jetzt gucken wir
uns noch mal an was wir im wire shark gecaptured haben ob recent darf man nicht was wir im wire
shark gecaptured haben beim am anfang vom putt aber wenn ich hab es falsche schwachsinn
putt was da hallo wim hero wim hero black ops 1 ist ja ewig her
das einzige problem ist jetzt auch das ein bisschen knackt beim aufbauen
von der Verbindung
achso und es ist übrigens
absolut standardkonform
wie wir das gemacht haben
weil es jetzt eine billig
china cam ist
wie hier ist das
wie hässlich er da
hässlich wie die lacht
die kamera, sieh wirklich hässlich aus
aber sie ist vandal
resistent
also falls sich schon einige leute
jetzt bei euch gewünscht haben bei mir mal die kamera
einzuschlagen könnt ihr vergessen weil ich habe eine
vandal resistent
doppel
ok also ich wollte
ich wollte einsen schicken
hab ich gesagt
ich hab gesagt ich will einsen schicken
ok wo sind wir denn hier
start upload einsen will ich schicken
hier will ich einsen schicken
ok wir machen jetzt einfach
die
keine ahnung
ne 50
mal die sekunde
dann haben wir jetzt quasi hier
haben wir
ne halbe sekunde
ja 20
wir schicken jetzt einfach 20
20 time frames
dann quasi
aber das sind lang das sind 400
millisekunden
200 millisekunden
200 millisekunden schicken wir mal
einsen
noch was schönes für das grill gefunden
leider noch nicht
meinst du man bekommt ein
bluetooth headset über dem raspberry angesprochen
ja
also du musst das natürlich pairn können
oder was
oder was willst du machen
also audio geht auf jeden
fall
ne bluetooth mit
wireshark dampen weiß gar nicht ob das
das kann
ja audio geht auf jeden fall wenn du
das ding mit bluetooth pairs kannst ja machen
die haben ja mittlerweile alle bluetooth on board
dann müsste das ding einfach als audiogerät erscheinen
wenn du das pairn kannst
mit
deinem handy zum beispiel
oder deinem fernseh oder irgendwas was
bluetooth kann dann kannst du das auch mit einem raspberry pairn
das überhaupt kein ding
ja gut dann wirst du schlechte chancen
an wenn du das nicht pairn kannst
aber ein bluetoothgerät ohne zu pairn funktioniert
in der regel nicht also was ist das denn für ein bluetooth headset
wie mit was verwendet man
das denn wenn man das nicht pairn kann als audiogerät
das kann man ja quasi gar nicht als
als gerät verwenden
ach es funktioniert
nur mit der hersteller bluetooth soundkarte
oh ne
also wenn der hersteller da nicht
geschlammt hat wird das wirst du schlechte karten haben
das wird nicht nur
irgendwelche proprietäre scheiße sein sondern auch noch
zusätzlich irgendwie verschlüsselt oder so das kannst du vergessen
also ich will nicht ausschließen dass es nicht
doch irgendwie geht
weil die hersteller verkacken sauer auf das mal
aber die chancen stehen relativ schlecht
guck mal ich spreche jetzt hier auch die kamera
quasi auf einem komplett proprietären
herstellerweg an
und der grund warum
das funktioniert ist weil es nicht verschlüsselt ist
wenn es verschlüsselt wäre ich keine
chancen gehabt
naja
so ganz stimmt es nicht
man kann meistens auch
ssl unter windows mitschneiden
oder man kann bei vielen sachen
ssl mitschneiden entweder mit
einem proxy wo man dann quasi
im browser sagt oder
irgendwo sagt ja kehl vertraut man
mit zertifikaten oder was
auch so ein ding ist
die ssl libraries austauschen
gegen libraries die mitschneiden
wenn das dynamisch gelingt ist das geht auch
aber ansonsten wenn du einfach nur die leitung
mitschneiden kannst dann
die krasse gelitten
also ich glaube du hast
so schlechte karten für
ok wir senden jetzt mal
nullen
und wenn das funktioniert
bin ich happy
wir brauchen wieder einen buffer
ein buffer von
bytes
wie viel mal heute ich heute
buffer geschrieben habe hier
so jetzt brauchen wir leider nochmal eine
schleife
und zwar eine schleife
um in diesen buffer
überall
1 zu schreiben
china buffer nennt
ja die ist leider eingebaut
hätte ich die gebaut dann
würde das ding auch china buffer heißen
so
so jetzt haben wir den buffer eins
und stehen
und jetzt sagen wir stream write
den buffer da rein
den buffer
null
so
und jetzt sleepen wir wieder unsere
sleepen wir
wieder unsere zwanzig sekunde
wir können
übrigens das sleep noch schöner machen wir können da
unsere
wir können da unsere fps counter
sleep loop
verwenden dann ist das auch vom timing
her genauer
das was wir in dem
gif dald xd coder gemacht haben
so jetzt schreiben wir da nullen rein
wir müssen noch ne sache machen
ne wir starten das recording
einfach danach
wir starten einfach das
recording danach
so und
das heißt
wir schreiben da jetzt nullen rein
eins
ich weiß auch nicht warum was ich mit nullen hab
gerade ich schreib ff
von sachen nullen
oh
das hat
komische geräusche gemacht jetzt
machen wir mal zwanzig
wow
vielleicht soll ich doch mal
nullen reinschreiben
das knackst immer noch
naja
f
18 ms
wow
ok das mit eins reinschreiben
ist doch keine so gute idee
schreib ich doch
nullen rein
ja
das funktioniert ganz gut
da knackst nur
kurz
weil wenn ich das weg mache
knackst auch
nur
braucht keiner
ne
brauchen wir nicht
das ist
ist komplett useless
das ich hier gebaut hab
es könnte aber auch
sein
dass es am recorder liegt
also wir schreiben jetzt
hier mal
eins rein und dann
lesen wir
in dem gleichen
maße da
den krempel
wieder raus mal gucken wie sich das jetzt anhört
äh
vergesst
ne
kann man vergessen
aber es ist ja nicht schlimm da knackst halt kurz
weil es knackst ja nicht
es macht ja dieses einschalte
geräusch das geht wahrscheinlich nicht anders
ja aber das ist echt nice
wir haben jetzt eine gegensprecher anlage am start
gegensprecher stellt
gegensprecher
test
nice
waren das wirklich nur eins
oder
ich würde jetzt mal sagen dass das da
nur einsen waren so
mehr einsen
geht aber nicht in den beid rein
ok das geht eigentlich nicht
das ist böse eigentlich
das sind
ja stimmt im china dampf waren noch ein paar andere
im china dampf waren irgendwie noch
noch 15 und
16 und 15
und so drinnen
aah
over the hell
ja richtig
komm mal da
siehste
ja natürlich
das hab ich nicht gesehen
jetzt ist wir haben in den buffer überhaupt nichts reingeschrieben
oh
jetzt ist es jetzt ist komplett leise
jetzt
machts gar nichts mehr
jetzt kann man das recording auch dahinter
ja klein viel macht auch
ja es wirklich ist
das zeug sieht man immer sieht man einfach
test
jetzt komplett
jetzt komplett ruhig
nice
ich muss am ende noch unbedingt das close einbauen
weil sonst hat er aber am nächsten mal
noch reste vom ersten gespräch drinne
wenn ich jetzt hier auf play drücke ist teilweise
schon noch der rest zu hören
was
irgendwie fail ist
for each
loop doch
was willst du mit for each machen
was meinste was du
das hier
oder was
das geht mit for each nicht weil du mit for each nicht
element modifizieren
darfst
wobei oder
ne du darfst doch
du darfst das element modifizieren
du darfst die collection nicht
ändern doch das müsste mit einem for each gehen
ich bin mal wobei ich bin jetzt gar nicht so sicher
wenn ich glaube doch das müsste
das müsste eigentlich gehen mit einem
ne
geht nicht darfst
du nicht
darfst die collection im for each
nicht ändern
also und die
elemente der collection darfst du im for each nicht ändern
so war es genau
wobei es bestimmt
eine schönere variante gibt
einen array auf
eins zu initialisieren
da muss es irgendwas geben
irgendwas wo ich nicht drauf
das ist ja die klassischste variante
schlechthin
gibt es vielleicht sowas wie
new array
warte mal new list
byte
gibt es nicht
memset
ja sowas würde funktionieren
ja
also
darf ich hier sowas machen
wahrscheinlich auch nicht
ah ja das dürfte ich machen
oder was
das ist ja fast schon javascript hässlich
weil ich mir nicht sicher bin ob das jetzt auch funktioniert hat
das hat funktioniert
also das darf man
aber ne for each schleife darf man nicht machen
oh auskenn folks
da hab ich ja überhaupt nicht dran gedacht
ja das ist ne gute idee
das ist ne gute idee
ich mein das sieht wirklich javascript hässlich aus
oder
ja aber das ist das ist das ne gute idee
ach ne
das finde ich
ne recht elegante lösung muss ich sagen
das finde ich ne recht elegante lösung
160 mal
das ist fast noch schöner als mit dem cast oder
das finde ich ganz hübsch so
das gefällt mir eigentlich recht gut
ja gibt es sowas wie nc sharp
ah guck mal hier
da macht das genauso wie da auskenn fox geschrieben hat
moment vielleicht ist das ja in morelink drinne
also nicht der nicht zelda ne
oh der war schlecht
oh war schlecht
ah
ich sag euch diese library ist echt nice
die ist wirklich nice
und die ist zum größten teil relativ simpel
auch wenn man sich die die sachen auf github anguckt
programmiert
ich glaube so geht das nicht ne
fill
forward
wie benutzt man das jetzt
so
ne
so nennt man das
ich wette mir hier es gibt genug sachen wo das der fall ist
zwar nichts offizielles
wie funktioniert das denn jetzt
macht das vielleicht nicht das was ich mir vorstelle
das macht wahrscheinlich nicht was ich mir vorstelle
das macht was anderes
null reference or value in source replaced
ach das na okay
ne das macht was anderes
das macht was anderes
ja da muss ich sagen dann hat der auskenn fox gewonnen
und zwar damit
das finde ich ganz hübsch
finde ich nicht schlecht
das hat was
und ich finde es schöner als die c++ variante
die ihr gerade alle im chat schreiben
c++ ist irgendwie alles
zwar nicht javascript hässlich
aber
unnötig mit sonderzeichen folgen
unnötig mit sonderzeichen folgekleistern
vor allem
vor allem die
die dings hier die
wie heißt das
wie heißt das in c++
diese elamerator
iterator
wo du dann irgendwie ne schleife machen musst
von beginn bis end
und so anstatt
das ist irgendwie sehr
auch die lambda synthax
in c
in c++
das ist ja irgendwie mit den klammern
und da musst du ja irgendwie sagen
du willst referenzen
ich weiß jetzt gerade aus dem kopf nicht wie es geht ne
du willst
ach was weiß ich
c++ 20 alles besser
also c++ ist schon deutlich besser geworden
die letzten jahre ja das stimmt aber
ich hoffe das das wird
und wenn automa so gut
funktioniert wie war in
c sharp dann
ich hoffe c++
wird mal wieder ne sprache
oder wird wieder zu ner sprache
die mir spaß macht zu verwenden
weil das hat unbeschreibbare vorteile
was ja noch cool wäre
wenn es mal nen ordentlichen
package manager gibt
da sagen natürlich
die c++ verfechter das braucht man nicht
das reichen ja auch
source code und header files von
github zum selbst reinkopieren und sowas
aber so ein ordentlicher
ja aber da ist kaum was
drinne
also das letzte mal wo ich
bei c++ package manager geguckt hab
oder ist es dieses neue
microsoft ding vc package
also den würd ich ja zutrauen sowas
zu etablieren weil das ist
ein riesen vorteil den quasi
alle neueren sprachen haben
dotnet
hat es ja auch mit
nougat jetzt noch nicht so
lang also schon lang aber
noch nicht sein
anfang an
haben sie sich das ja was ausgedacht
aber alle sprachen die quasi
so die letzten
zehn jahre rausgekommen sind die haben
alle nen ordentlichen package manager ja
guckt euch doch mal an wie schön
das beispielsweise in ruby ist wie schön das
in rust ist
wie schön das mittlerweile in dotnet projekten
ist
ich mein
was ist besser
einfach mal zu sagen ok
ich brauche ich brauche ein package
eingeben
library downloaden ist verfügbar
oder auf github gehen
den headerfiles runterladen saucecode teilweise
runterladen oder gucken dass du da noch ne
precompiled geschichte findest
für deine plattform und dann
das headerfile dazu und
was ich auch nicht verstehe ist
warum
ähm
was wollte ich jetzt sagen äh mit
genau warum
sind c plus plus
leute so geil drauf oder
ich glaube gar nicht mal dass
das die programmierer unbedingt wollen die die
hauptsächlich in c plus plus erbeinen
sondern das ist quasi so
so
irgendwie so ungeschriebenes gesetz ist
warum ist man da so scharf drauf headerfiles
dass man das man überhaupt
headerfiles hat warum ist man so
scharf drauf ich mein ich verstehs insofern
dass man früher gesagt ja ok wenn du halt
was was dass du halt quasi
was
verwendet kannst ja
also quasi dass es dass du
die signaturen und und gedönse
mit kriegst
dass du halt weißt
wie du die die anderen
library geschichten so aufrufen musst
aber ich weiß
ich aber im jahr 2018 immer noch
immer noch headerfiles
weil es ist nervig
code und headerfiles getrennt muss
man ja auch mal sagen das ist das geht das geht
ultra auf den sack du scrollst
dich erstmal durch eine 20.000
zeilenlange c++ header fall durch
und danach musst du dann irgendwie
feststellen dass teilweise ein bisschen
logik im header steht allerdings der größte teil der
logik steht dann irgendwie in der klasse dazu
also
ich finde das wie
das beispielsweise muss ich mal sagen
java haben sie das ja schon von Anfang an so gemacht
auch wenn ich kein java fan bin
und in
sprachen die ich so kenne sogar
in rust, rust hat keine
klasse in dem sen ja aber da hast du auch
definition
und implementierung ist da
ban
von interfaces und sowas abgesehen aber
das ist einfach an der stelle wo
du es findest
da verstehe ich nicht
da gibt es schönere
möglichkeiten mittlerweile
ja man könnte das im zweifelsfall doch auch
irgendwie da reinkompilen oder so
so ein debug signaturen
file ja
was ich
wieso mögen so viele
kein java das liegt
hauptsächlich an java software würde ich mal behaupten
wobei java hat ein paar
merkwürdige sachen haben die mittlerweile generics
die hatten jahre lang keinen generics
ja und eine
Sache ist bei java extrem ausgeprägt
das ist
alles zu
über objekt orientieren
das ist jetzt ein bisschen bescheuert
ausgedrückt aber was ich meine
ist
die
man kann das in modernen java bestimmt
anders machen habe ich keine ahnung von aber
java
neigt dazu alles
zu sehr aufzusplitten
ja also wenn du jetzt quasi
ne tür hast durch die du durchgehen
kannst
würdest du quasi in der objekt orientierten
logik würdest du dann sagen machen
sowas wie was weiß ich du hast
ne klasse door die hat ne metode
klopfen und ne metode öffnen
und ne metode schließen so
das wäre die normale logik wie man so was
wie man sowas machen würde
in java hast du erstmal eine door factory
damit gehts da schon erstmal los
du kriegst du kannst nicht einfach
ein new door oder so
die door kommt dann erstmal aus der door factory
ja und die door factory
hat natürlich noch einen door factory manager
dass ich mir eine door factory erstellen kann
dafür dass ich doors bekomme
dann hab ich aus dann brauch ich erstmal den passenden
door factory manager die door factory
und nachher kann ich mir dann ein door erstellen
und das door braucht noch zig
provider und service gedöns
das ich überhaupt klopfen kann
dann hab ich einen knocking provider und ein
ein open service
und da übertreiben
da hat es in der vergangenen java maßlos
übertrieben das war wirklich
auch sehr hässlich sich das anzugucken
das ist zumindest mein
halbnagel gegenüber java
und die
factories sind nicht java spezifisch
das stimmt allerdings wird das in java
ganz gerne
auf die spitze getrieben
diese geschichte ja
du hast in java so viele
ewig lange klassen das heißt du nicht dass du es
in anderen sprachen machen kannst ein
provider factory manager
of
door
opener factories
oder irgendwie sowas
du hast in java oft mal so dinge halbe
seite lang die dinger
ja genau
patrick sagt guckt euch die standard
library an das ist da teilweise ganz ganz
eklig
ja aber
man kann das bestimmt mittlerweile in java auch
schön machen wobei eine
weitere abneigung die ich gegen java habe
und die
ja
die
wie findest du pyson ist eine sehr schöne sprache
ich war
ja früher immer ein großer ruby
fan so die
als es noch um die frage ging
was für eine dynamische
sprache man so verwenden
ruby oder pyson man früher hat
das eine weile so ausgesehen als
als würde ruby quasi gewinnen
wenn man das so nennen kann so durch rails
mittlerweile kräht wirklich kein
han mehr nach rails
nichts weiß ich ob in letzter
zeit mal irgendwo ein schnelles angebot für rails
gesehen habt oder so
und pyson ist halt im
im wissenschaftlichen segment
und im kreativen
segment und so saumäßig verbreitet
und auch verwerbbar
mittlerweile für so nicht wirklich performance
kritische sachen also wenn
wenn mich heute einer fragen würde was soll ich lernen
pyson oder ruby würde ich sagen
allerdings finde ich ruby
immer noch
eleganter
schöner ist es nicht unbedingt wenn man es
eklig schreibt
aber ruby ist der king
wenn es um kurz und knackig geht
ja ich muss auch sagen ich bin auch der
ansicht dass objektorientierung
oftmals viel zu übertrieben wird
da muss ich dem dem dem green monster
recht geben also erstens
überbewertet
sehe ich auch so viele
sachen muss man nicht objektorientiert
machen vor allem wenn es komplett
kontraproduktiv ist ja
also ich muss nicht nur um klassen
zu machen klassen machen
also nur weil quasi
irgendwann einer gesagt hat objektorientiert
muss man klassen machen
muss ich das nicht unbedingt
tun wenn ich wenn ich sachen habe die
einfach zusammengehören die aber
in der echten welt keine logische einheit
kann ich es trotzdem in eine klasse stecken
keine drei klassen dafür machen
muss es nicht übertreiben
das muss das muss irgendwie
einfach
greifbar sein und das ist eigentlich das wichtigste
egal in welcher sprache man sollte
das so basteln dass das möglichst einfach
zu verstehen ist
das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran
weil du überall diese so selbst ernannte gurus
hast die dir dann erklären wollen
erklären wollen so bist du
agil so bist du objektorientiert so bist du
funktional so funktioniert das ja und nur
so und dann musst du hier design
pattern a design pattern b design
pattern e scheiß egal ob das jetzt irgendwie
sinn macht oder nicht
und dann glauben viele leute
nach dem motto oh nein meine
meine mein code verstößt
gegen design pattern 875
jetzt kann ich das nicht
einchecken das geht nicht ich muss jetzt
erstmal aus dieser klasse 5 unterklassen machen
dass das dass das solid ist und
dass das try ist und dann ist das das
ach was es noch alles für einen scheiß gibt
einfach verständlich machen
kurz und einfach
schlägt einfach alles
scheiß drauf ob das dann vielleicht
objektorientierte sachen
umso kürzer und umso simpler
so schneller ist das in der regel
umso einfacher checken das andere
leute umso weniger fehler hast du
drinne
kurz und knackig und
ich wobei
ich finde die
also grundsätzlich die sache
dass man metoden keine 500 zeit
machen soll finde ich schon sinnvoll ja
aber so
diese starren sachen so nach dem
motto es muss auf eine seite passen
oder es kommt immer drauf
an das muss es nicht unbedingt
ja wenn du jetzt es ist
so nervig wenn du wenn du irgendwie code
aufmachst
ähm
warte mal
es ist so nervig wenn du irgendwie code aufmachst
und weißt ok
prinzipiell passiert in der
start download methode was was ich suche
und dann scrollst du hier durch
und bis du
durch start download durch bist wurden
40 andere metoden aufgerufen
die jeweils nur aus 2
zeilen bestehen
da kann mir keiner
der selbst ernannten
ähm
best practice gurus oder so
erklärt erzählen dass das besser
ist als die logik untereinander
zu schreiben wo man sie einfach verstehen kann da ist es
halt ein bisschen länger scheiß drauf aber du kannst die
logik untereinander lesen und verstehen
ich hab mal ne
präsentation geguckt von irgendwie so einem
rubi guru
irgendwie fahr mich
ein bernstein oder so glaube ich
irgendwie ein rubi guru
und da hat allen ernstes
hat er in seiner präsentation erzählt
ähm
hat er angefangen mit so nach dem motto
das ist ein code smell das ist auch
immer so ein geiles wort für das
das sieht schon danach aus als ist es was nicht richtig
und da hat er allen ernstes gesagt
dass seiner ansicht nach
alles
quasi ein code smell ist
wenn die methode mehr als eine
zeile hat wörtlich quote
aus dieser präsentation von dem
dude ja mehr als eine
zeile
ja das tut doch
schon weh
kann man sowas erzählen
so als habe ich den chat aber komplett verpasst
ja ja typescript java script
ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
was war denn die frage
lohnt es sich php zu lernen
das kommt drauf an was du machen willst
ja also wenn du zum beispiel
ähm deine anwendung
laufen lassen möchtest auf so
den 0815 web hosting
angeboten dann lohnt sich das php zu lernen
weil die meisten angebote
haben nun mal php und als datenbank
meistens
oder so was oder maria oder so
dann lohnt
sich das und das ist das was ich auch sonst immer sage
am besten ist man macht das an dem fest
was man
machen will und wenn du sagst du hast
eine anwendung so was weiß ich irgendwie so eine
eine statistik site für deinen
battlefield server fällt mir so gerade ein
als beispiel das habe
ich habe ich auch mal was in php dafür gemacht
als ich noch einen battlefield
4 oder 3 server hatte
tom battlefield 4 server war das
ähm da habe ich auch so eine php
statistik site gebaut für die
für die leute wieviel kills sie haben und
wieviel stunden sie gespielt haben auf dem
server und solche dinge so ein bisschen
konnte man sich angucken das habe ich in php
gemacht weil ich das auf eben so 0815
web hosting laufen lassen wollte
aber wenn man was neues lernt
als einsteiger dann ist
tatsächlich die sache mit typescript
und javascript nicht verkehrt
wenn man irgendwie was im bereich
von web machen will und eigentlich
ist heute fast alles
zumindest teilweise irgendwie mit web
ich meine sogar mein komisches
meme board was bildchen anzeigt ist
web bis auf
das programm was anzeigt
warum platt ich eigentlich den resize button
hier unten ein
ich soll das button mal weg machen
warum labert da im hintergrund eigentlich einer
das ist aber kein
krasser chillstep
doch jetzt jetzt wupp wupp wupp
jetzt ist es wieder chillstep
instagram benutzt jungle oder was meinst du
mit nicht performance critic
twitter hat am anfang auch
ruby verwendet und sind jetzt
mittlerweile ich glaube auf java
und man kann das schon
man kann das bestimmt auch ordentlich
scale in jungle
und es gibt bestimmt auch die ein oder
anderen tricks wie man pyzen sachen
schneller machen kann
aber alles in allem ist pyzen relativ
lahm
das ist nicht weil ich es nicht mag
finde ich sprache an sich super
aber performance ist definitiv
nicht die stärke
ups warum habe
ich das bild eigentlich noch eingeblendet
so
liest du auf der arbeit viel code von
anderen leuten wenn ja gibt es negativ
positiv beispiel für guten code ich liest
fast den ganzen tag nur code von anderen
auf der arbeit
wie gesagt ich kümmere mich um unsere
code source
repos
und das heißt ich lese hier quasi den ganzen Tag nur Code von anderen
gibt es Sachen, gibt es negative und positive Beispiele
fällt mir jetzt grad nichts ein, also
die, die ganz, ganz schlimme Sachen habe ich ja schon teilweise
anonymisiert auf
twitter gepostet
so
wann hast du mit programming angefangen?
also
das erste, das aller, aller
erste was ich gemacht habe
muss man überlegen
also wo ich, wo ich, sag mal mal so
da wo ich angefangen habe, weil es mich richtig interessiert hat, nicht weil ich es
machen musste
weil wir mussten mal in der Schule ein bisschen zäh machen und da hab ich
damals fand ich das richtig beschissen, da hatte ich ja überhaupt kein
überhaupt kein Zugang zu
und was war denn C? Du kannst die Leute nicht mit C anfangen lassen, das ist total behämmert
da hat keiner Bock, wenn du die Leute mit C anfangen lässt, dann ist es vorbei
später vielleicht, wenn sie sagen, ja das ist das was ich jetzt brauche, aber nicht zum
Einstieg, zum Einstieg ist kein C
das erste was ich
wo ich so richtig angefangen habe mich dafür zu interessieren war
wo ich mir ein
objektorientiertes
Python Buch gekauft hab
ich gucke jetzt mal ein paar Amazon wann das war
das ist, das ist noch in meiner Amazon-Historie drin
ähm
100%
What? No Results Found? Warum?
Oh meines, die Scharpbücher sind dann immer drinne
warum?
hat Amazon die History irgendwie?
ne, wobei meine History geht bis 2004 zurück
hab ich das vielleicht nicht bei Amazon bestellt damals?
also das wundern mich jetzt irgendwie, aber
ja gut ähm
ich denke mal das war so 2003 oder so
würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, so in dem Dreh
also ich hab erst ein bisschen mit Python rumgebastelt und
das ging mir danach in der Zeit irgendwie auf den Keks
und dann hab ich mir einen
ich bin nicht klar was die Reihenfolge war, ich glaub dann hab ich mir das
ich glaub dann hab ich mir das Galileo
das Galileo Open Book C-Sharp
den geschnappt, das müsste auch so 2004 oder so gewesen sein
und hab damit dann richtig angefangen
Python hat mich nicht begeistert zum Einstieg muss ich sagen damals, aber das ist noch schon ewig her
und bis heute ich hab mit C-Sharp mehr oder weniger angefangen so richtig
wo es mich dann
wirklich auch
angefangen hat extrem zu interessieren und das ist bis heute noch meine Lieblingssprache
das muss man erstmal schaffen ne
also ich mein so schlecht kann das nicht sein was Microsoft da produziert hat
ja Axel
dafür ist Python super
ja generell so in Bildungseinrichtungen und in der Forschung und so Python ist aber ganz toll
du hast so Sachen wie diese wie die Notebooks wie heißt das
diese
diese Python Notebooks wo du quasi
Text und Code zusammenschreiben kannst, das ist super für Vorträge und sowas
hier Rack 16 wir verwenden Git
oder wie es manche bei uns nennen JIT
was total hängen geblieben ist
bei uns sagen manche Leute JIT dazu
was
und wenn wir dann mal irgendwann drauf gekommen sind
wenn es auch Shit heißt dann bin ich quasi der Shitmaster
weil ich mich um die ganzen Repos kümmere
aber es ist Git
es heißt auch Git, es heißt nicht JIT
Jithub
will eher wissen ob Max
eine Systemintegratorin Arbeit oder Einwendungsentwicklerarbeit macht, nix
nix dergleichen
sowas modern ausgedrückt nennt man das eher DevOps was ich mache
es ist eigentlich so genau dazwischen
ich programmiere relativ wenig auch wenn ich
selber auch wenn ich gerne wieder programmieren würde aber
bis aus ein paar Kleinigkeiten ist da auf der Arbeit nicht viel drinnen
aber ich lese halt viel Code von anderen
und wie gesagt kümmere ich um unsere
Source Code Repos
und schau dass wir einmal im Monat eine neue Version rauskriegen
bzw. eine neue Version einspielen
auf allen Systemen und das sind so ungefähr 2000 Stück
und es kriegen natürlich nicht alle exakt das gleiche das wäre zu einfach
Hab im Studium C++ beigebracht bekommen was kann man damit aktuell anfangen?
Wenn du Spiele entwickeln willst viel
damit kannst du alles machen was du willst C++
ist eigentlich eine der Sprachen wo wirklich
alles geht
aber wirklich alles
aber halt ein bisschen
steiniger Weg bei vielen Sachen
Ja, Jupyter Notebooks genau das meine ich
was sind die nächsten Programmsprojekte erst mal
also wir haben so viel Zeug angefangen
das Meme Tool muss fertig werden
das müssen wir nämlich releasen auf GitHub
das hier
das muss fertig werden
das wollen wir nämlich auf GitHub veröffentlichen
Danach muss ich noch ein bisschen
am Hardware Arttool basteln
wobei wir das jetzt ja schon den ganzen Dezember verwendet haben und im Dezember
werden viele PCs gebaut das heißt
grundsätzlich funktioniert das wohl ziemlich gut
meine Gegensprecherlage muss ich noch weiter basteln die wir heute angefangen haben
ja das sind so die nächsten mal das Zeug fertig machen
Moin was meinst du wie schwer es ist ein Programm zu schreiben was gespielte
Noten einer E-Gitarre abhört und in Tastatur Input umwandelt damit man damit
Gäms als Channels hat
du meinst dass du quasi anhand des Tons
irgendwie eine Taste drückt je nachdem welchen Ton du spielst sollte auch das
dürfte nicht so schwer sein
du musst halt gucken dass du die Töne schön einzeln spielst und und
auch dementsprechend nicht so sehr ineinander überblendest oder so
Ansonsten wird es mathematisch bestimmt ein bisschen komplizierter
ich habe jetzt zwei Jahre mit Python programmiert ich möchte mal eine andere
Ausprämie hast du irgendwelche Empfehlungen
kommt auch an in welchem Bereich willst du denn was machen
was schweben die denn für Anwendungszwecke so vor
Spiele programmieren
da bleibt ja fast nur noch
entweder Junity mit C-Sharp
wobei man das nicht nur mit C-Sharp machen kann
oder Mono Game oder sowas wenn es 2D sein soll
generell also Spiele Programmierung ist ja dann auch
oftmals ein bisschen winter spezifisch
da fährst du mit C-Sharp definitiv nicht schlecht
C-Sharp kannst du in Unity verwenden das ist eigentlich das Ding schlechthin
für Unity
und du kannst das auch
natürlich für alles andere verwenden
das ist nicht verkehrt
und man lernt auch vieles
was einem in anderen Sprachen was bringt
generell kann ich C-Sharp eigentlich nur empfehlen vor allem jetzt
nachdem das Microsoft Open Source hat und ein übelstes Tempo bei der Entwicklung
vorlegt
die Sprache ist
mittlerweile schon wirklich ausgewachsen ja die gibt es ja schon ein paar Jahre
und trotzdem gibt es
permanent jetzt gerade wieder neue Sachen geile Sachen also
und es wird auch also.NET Core ist mittlerweile wirklich ziemlich schnell
also man hat fast keine Ausrede mittlerweile mehr
dass man
quasi Teile in C machen muss
für Performance in C-Sharp
spätestens jetzt nicht mehr
seitdem es quasi
quasi sowas wie Pointer nur in Safe Variante gibt
wobei das kommt glaube ich erst mit C-Sharp
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es
gibt es das nicht schon
für.NET Core
es könnte schon sein also
es wird auf jeden Fall es gibt es gibt es jetzt gerade schon
also entweder jetzt ziemlich genau
die letzte Version schon
und es wird es in der nächsten Version geben gibt es quasi in C-Sharp gibt es sowas wie Pointer
dann allerdings Safe
Safe Pointer gibt es dann
was ziemlich cool ist
für Performance Geschichten
Java ist das beste
ist klar Leute
das klappt in Python klar
kannst du das kannst du in
die Aschen dann sowas kannst du in jeder Programmiersprache machen
du brauchst halt die passenden
die passenden Bindings für irgendwelche Libraries die du verwenden willst
weil du wirst es wahrscheinlich
nicht alles
komplett von Hand machen wollen selbst das ist dann ein bisschen zu
du brauchst eine Library mit der du ordentlich Input simulieren kannst
du brauchst irgendwas für die Sounds
also
das kannst du in Python machen
Was hältst du von CTF Games?
Ich gehe mal davon aus das CTF in dem Fall nicht für Capture the Flag steht oder?
gibt es nicht auch Pointer schon in C naja klar
C ist ein Pointer
es ist nur interessant dass es jetzt in C-Sharp quasi sowas wie Pointer gibt
obwohl es ja
obwohl es ja Safe ist im Vergleich zu C
also kannst du ja in C-Sharp gar nicht auf
in Bereiche schreiben wo du jetzt nicht schreiben willst das funktioniert ja gar nicht
was ist das Besondere an Safe-Pointern?
dass sie Safe sind also sprich
dass sie
nicht Null sind oder
dass sie nicht undefiniert sind halt
immer auf irgendwas Gültiges zeigen
das trifft es glaube ich am besten bei Safe-Pointern
Programmier mal weiter ich bin fertig für heute
fertig für heute wir haben alles geschafft guck
falls du jetzt erst dazu kommst ich zeig es dir mal
Kamera Input funktioniert
Gegensprechen funktioniert auch
blub blub blub
funktioniert Gegensprecher Lare tut
klappt
stopp jetzt auf die Kamera
man hört mich aus der Kamera funktioniert alles
easy
Matt sowas habe ich noch nie ausprobiert aber das klingt nicht schlecht
das klingt nach einer guten Idee
habe ich noch nie gemacht sowas aber
das ist eine coole Sache
ich weiß dass C plus plus auch sowas hat
aber es ist halt einfach das geile dass es das jetzt in C sharp auch gibt
es gibt sich andere Sprachen mit Pointern
ich wollte ich will damit nicht sagen dass Pointer was was neues sind
sondern für C sharp verhältnisse das neu
bisher konntest du in C sharp konntest du ja auch schon immer Pointer verwenden
du musst es aber sagen
unsafe
und dann konntest du auch sowas hier machen
in Pointer blub
das übrigens wo wir gerade bei unsafe sind
das brauche ich ja hier bei meinen FFmpeg
bei meinen FFmpeg Geschichten
da ist ja auch die ganze Klasse ist unsafe weil FFmpeg direkt C bindings sind
das ist auch alles unsafe
hier free
unref
merkst du halt dass es direkt zu FFmpeg C bindings also C Geschichten geht
können wir die ASCII Fische haben? ja kann man machen
ach stimmt ich könnte mal gucken wie weit mein Raspberry mit Kompilieren ist
wir machen die ASCII Fische einmal
so und jetzt mal gucken wie weit ist denn mein Raspberry mit Kompilieren
ist der jetzt fertig?
boah ist fertig krass
FFmpeg Kompiliert wie lang hat es gedauert? man sieht es leider nicht mehr
aber wahrscheinlich irgendwie
drei Stunden oder so
FFmpeg
so jetzt kann ich das nämlich mal ausprobieren
warum ich FFmpeg Kompiliert habe auf meinem Raspberry ist
für den Hardware H264 Decoder
der irgendwie in dem offiziellen Bild nicht so richtig funktioniert hat
ich lese mir gleich die roten Sachen im Chat durch mal kurz gucken ob es funktioniert
FFmpeg
Codex
Grab nach
Jap und nach
OX oder so hieß das? ne
OX
was ist das für ein Desktop Environment? das ist I3
okay jetzt probieren wir mal ob der Krampel jetzt mittlerweile funktioniert
mit dieser FFmpeg Version hier
ach scheiße
das funktioniert einfach nicht
das Stream von der Kamera ist einfach voll im Arsch, den schluckt FFmpeg nicht
also mein Ziel ist eigentlich gewesen
weil das ist ein Raspberry Zero, das Ding hat absolut keine CPU Power
mein Ziel ist eigentlich gewesen den Kamerastream
mit dem Hardware H264
ach du scheiße mit dem Raspberry
Hardware H264 Decoder zu decoden
und danach wieder
mit ein paar geänderten Parametern mit dem Raspberry H264
Encoder
wieder zu encoden
und das funktioniert auch, bloß mit diesem Stream funktioniert das nicht
wenn ich das jetzt zum Beispiel mit einer MP4 Testdatei mache, die ich hier habe
ja
sollte man vielleicht auch nicht sagen, dass das ein Stream ist
funktioniert das wunderbar
zack, kompiliert
kaum CPU Last, guckt es euch an
easy as fuck
50% CPU Last, kein Ding
funktioniert gut
ähm
aber mit dem Stream funktioniert es einfach nicht
so, jetzt lese ich mal den Chat, da war ja viel Zeug noch dabei
also die ASCII Fische wolltet ihr haben
da haben wir die ASCII Fische
ich hätte sogar noch den ASCII Train
aber ich hab vergessen, wie der ASCII Train heißt
wie hieß der denn?
wollen wir mal gucken
wie ist das denn?
egal, komm ich jetzt immer drauf
oh, die Fische, machen wir mal an
SL, ja genau
das ist immer installiert
achso
da, den hätten wir auch noch zu bieten
wobei, die Fische sind besser
ok, ähm
was hältst du davon, dass man
Fachinformatik und System-Integratoren
System-Integratoren den gleichen Müll wie für Anwendungsentwicklung lernen
wenn man davon abgesehen, dass ich Berufsschule prinzipiell für Müll halte
eigentlich gibt es keinen großartigen Unterschied
weil klar, die meisten Leute, die Anwendungsentwicklung lernen
werden wir später was programmieren
die System-Integratoren machen vielleicht eher ein bisschen Netzwerkzeug
aber es gibt da mittlerweile so große Überschneidungen
heute sollte es eigentlich exakt sein
eigentlich braucht man diese beiden
es müsste eigentlich nicht getrennt sein
wir verarschen dann sowas immer gut, wenn du auf GitHub guckst, was es für Programme gibt, die sowas in der Richtung machen
wie das, was du haben willst
allerdings, ich würde es einfach mal probieren
warum bist du kein Twitch-Partner, weil du mich noch nicht beworben hast
was ist dein Lieblingssortier-Algorithmus?
oder Gartenzwergesort?
Gartenzwergesort ist auch geil
zumindest vom Namen her
läuft der Raspberry dabei heiß?
ne, wenn man das mit dem Hardware-Encode anmacht, nicht
wenn man das mit der CPU macht, dann packt der das gar nicht
also ein Raspberry Zero, da packt was, was ich bei einem 720p A264-Video 1 FPS oder so
Green Monster, den E3 haben wir sogar im Stream eingerichtet zusammen
ich hab sogar je nach Anmeldung wechselnde Backgrounds und sowas
bringst danke für die ganzen Follows
ich komm mal kurz rein
ich noch ein paar Sehe
wie findest du 144 Herzmonitore in Kombination mit IPS?
144 Herzmonitore sind immer gut
Selmore?
wahrscheinlich eher im Stream
wir haben die Desktop-Geschichte im Stream zusammen eingerichtet
mussten wir beim Sebaro immer schief gucken, wenn dich das interessiert
ansonsten für YouTube ist das eher nichts
leider, leider
glaube ich auf YouTube ist das für die meisten Leute nicht so toll
Jago's Gaming, ich bin schon fertig mit dem Programming
Telinde Mann und Haftbefehl, oh ja das wollten wir uns auch noch angucken
das halte ich heute Abend mal aus
kennst du Stalin-Sort? Nein
Nein, kenne ich nicht, danach suche ich jetzt aber auch nicht
Wann fängt morgen der Streamer-Tschuld um die Uhrzeit an?
ist irgendwie 17, 18 Uhr
gar so früh lohnt sich erst, wenn die Leute Urlaub haben
der Töter postet schlecht
ein deutscher Streamer, der mit über 100 Zuschauer-Programmierungen live streamt
ein Wunder, wo hacks hast du denn die China?
wir sind schon fertig, aber ich kann es dir mal kurz zeigen, wenn du willst
wir sind fertig, China Audio
und zwar, was wir gemacht haben, ich habe relativ günstig eine China-CAM, eine China-Gegensprechanlage
mir geholt, weil es das als Angebot gab, das Ding ist zwar hässlich wie die Nacht
aber funktioniert, das Problem ist, dass sie nur mit der offiziellen App ordentlich funktioniert
vor allem auch die Gegensprechfunktion oder aber mit einem Internet Explorer ActiveX Plugin
was halt im Jahr 2018 absolut lächerlich ist
und ich habe ein bisschen mitgeschnitten mit Wireshark
was die Kamera denn so treibt, natürlich alles unverschlüsselt
ja, typisch China-CAM
darauf sind wir drauf gestoßen, in dem Wireshark-Dump
dass die China-CAM so einen China Websocket-Zeugs verwendet
also quasi sowas wie Websockets ohne Websockets zu sein
und das haben wir hier nachgebaut
und das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe, habe ich quasi so eine Mini-Gegensprechanlage gebaut
das heißt, wir haben hier einmal das Kamera
scheiß mal auf die hässliche Windform-Oberfläche, da ging es nicht drum
mit FFmpeg holen wir uns das Bild
und nicht FFmpeg im Hintergrund ausgefüllt, sondern richtig FFmpeg-C-Bindings
also die Hardcore-Variante
und wenn man hier auf Play drückt, dann, ich glaube du hörst
haben wir komplett Two-Way-Audio mit der Gegensprechanlage
vom Headset am Windows-Rechner zur Kamera übers WLAN
das haben wir heute gemacht
und aktuell will ich einfach nur ein bisschen Chat labern
Selmo, die Intel-Grafik-3-Bauter-Linux sind eigentlich mit die besten
also die sind im Prinzip alle kacke, aber Intel sind die, die sich am meisten Mühe geben mit Linux-Grafik
drei Mann
weil ich nichts zu sagen kann, wie das mit
wie das mit V-Sync und Tearing und so ist
also Transparenzen habe ich auch, aber sehr beschränkt hier mit
wie heißen die?
COMP
COMPTON, ah wobei habe ich das mit, das habe ich mittlerweile abgeschaltet
achso, ich habe es nach COMPTON gepiped WTF
ich wollte creppen danach
so viel habe ich da nicht
ich habe das eigentlich hauptsächlich dafür, dass
ja
mein Home ist schon echt unaufgeräumt, oder?
plupp-MP4, plupp-RAW, plupp-SH, plupp-WAF
Kapp, P-Kapp, Cheats
fuck, gucken wir jetzt nicht rein, ich weiß nicht, was es ist
Output 3, 4, 5, P3, PIA, die Piano Sounds natürlich auch
Snapshots, Zoom, was auch immer
Titanic MP3
wie macht man denn die Fische? AskIquarium
AskIquarium, das ist irgendein Pearl
irgendein Pearlscript, was die Fische macht
die Nidris sind random, die werden random galeriert
also wie sie schwimmen
ok, das mit AMD wusste ich nicht, dass die da auch mittlerweile gut sind
was, reingucken, POC
ne, ich weiß nicht, was ich da rumliegen habe, da gucken wir nicht rein
ich könnte mal wieder meine Platte aufräumen
guck mal, die Leiste hat sogar, ist sogar interaktiv
ich kann hier die Rahmenauslastung, kann ich, ne die Festplattenauslastung ist das
kann ich umstellen von Disc auf, ne das ist Rahmenauslastung
kann ich umstellen von Ram auf Swap und Swap ist 100%
weil ich keinen Swap dran hab
gut, das ist 2247, wir haben unser Progas Ziel erreicht
Gegensprechanlage funktioniert
jetzt muss ich mir nur noch überlegen
wie ich den Kram zum Beispiel, also was ich damit mache
ich hätte ja gerne, ich hätte ja gerne was, was auf jeder Plattform läuft
was im Prinzip eigentlich nur für eine Web Anwendung zutrifft so richtig
wenn man nicht irgendwelche App Store Geschichten machen will
und will ich nicht, für was was nur für mich ist im Endeffekt
ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie gut der Support auf IOS ist für Progressive Web Apps
weiß ich nicht, ob man mittlerweile mit PWA Apps auf IOS, ob man da Mikrofon Access kriegt
was ist das für eine Oberfläche, das ist Manjaro Linux mit I3
allerdings muss man sagen, das ist halt ein bisschen Custom I3
ich sag mal so, der Standard I3 da sieht jetzt nicht so schön aus
der Standard I3 sieht ungefähr
ne, das ist auch ein hübsch gemachter
ja, ja so sieht ungefähr der Standard I3 aus
das ist halt nicht so teuer
Software Decoding, wie kann man denn Software Decoding nicht unterstützen?
Software Decoding ist das, was immer geht
also Intel hat auf jeden Fall ein Hardware H264 Decoder
AV1 hat YouTube glaube ich auch nicht
YouTube hat H264 oder VP8 oder VP9 teilweise sogar schon
weiß ich nicht, können wir mal gucken, was mittlerweile YouTube für einen Standard
gucken wir mal unter Windows, kann man auch unter Windows gucken
was YouTube mittlerweile für einen Standard Encoding hat
gucken wir mal, was bei meinem letzten Video YouTube denn für einen Encoding hätte
gucken, ob das FFmpeg mittlerweile auch kann, aber ich glaube ja nicht
ne, aber YouTube.dl kann es mit Minus Crossf
ja, genau das sind die Formate, die mittlerweile bei VP9 ist das, was die hauptsächlich mittlerweile haben
oh doch, AVC1 tatsächlich
ah ne, man kann H264 hochladen, so rum, genau
aber das meiste ist mittlerweile VP9, ja und das kann Intel wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht
ja
ja, das ist tatsächlich blöd
packst du noch deine Switch an, mittlerweile, es gibt ernsthaft eine YouTube App für die Switch
hätte ich das von Nintendo gar nicht gedacht, dass quasi mal sowas essentielles auch kommt
Proser gibt es immer noch nicht, ne
Kodak Blacklist, kannst du nicht irgendwie beim Start das eintragen, ja aber das ist halt
das ist halt das, was unter Linux immer ein bisschen gefrickelt ist
das ist auch das, warum ich es eigentlich keinem aufzwinge
ja, also wenn mich die Leute danach fragen, ob ich ihnen irgendwas zeigen kann, was ich erklären kann, was helfen kann
oder irgendwie was, wenn sie es interessiert, dann mach ich auch was, ja
und wenn es ihnen dann gefällt und ich quasi so den ein oder anderen dazu gebracht habe, sich mal ein bisschen mit Linux zu beschäftigen, ist das gut
aber ich empfehle keinem normalen Anwender, dass er sich, also quasi jemand, der so komplett im Windows- oder Mac-Ökosystem irgendwie drinne hängt
empfehle ich nicht, steig auf Linux um, ja, da hast du im Endeffekt die ganze Arbeit und dann ziehst du dir noch den Hass der Leute zu
ja, vieles ist halt ein bisschen umständlich
und das ist halt so, das ist so
wie gesagt, das sage ich als Linux-Fan, als jemand, der sein Geld mit Linux verdient, als jemand, der sich auch seit Jahren mit Linux beschäftigt
das ist halt für den normalen Anwender nicht unbedingt immer das Beste
was nicht heißt, dass man das als normaler Anwender nicht nehmen kann, also
meine Mutter beispielsweise verwendet seit Jahren Ubuntu auf dem Notebook, überhaupt keine Probleme mit
wobei sie das Notebook auch jetzt schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr nimmt, sondern einfach eines der zig Tablets, die wir haben
ja, die Musik geht mir auf den Keks
ne, wenn ich jetzt auf YouTube switche, wollt ihr, dass ich Till Lindemann Feature als Haftbefehl anmache
das habe ich jetzt keinen Nerv drauf
denkst du, dass eine Linux-Distribution wie Chrome OS Windows ablösen wird?
Nö, es wird nicht Windows ablösen
es kommen sogar eher Mac-Anwender zu Windows mittlerweile
weil viele Leute die nervigen Sachen bei Apple-Lite sind
Apple hatte halt vor allem halt auf dem Desktop oder halt mit ihrem richtigen Macs
halt wirklich so ein Stein im Brett bei kreativen Leuten, bei Designer-Leuten
da sind so viele Dinge gelaufen in den letzten Jahren, die quasi komplett entgegen dieser Zielgruppe sind
das viele von denen schon mittlerweile gesagt haben, hey, Windows, easy
ISO Press, es stimmt insofern, gebe ich dir recht, das reicht prinzipiell für die normalen Anwender aus
aber die Leute wollen halt nicht gerne sich umgewöhnen
und der Umstieg von Windows 7 auf Windows 10 kannst du wirklich nicht mit Linux vergleichen
wenn die jemanden haben, oh, ich habe deine Nachricht aus Versehen gelöscht, das wollte ich gar nicht
WTF, ich war mit der Maus gerade drüber, ich wollte dich nicht sperren
WTF, ja ich beantworte deine Frage weiter, ich habe dich auch wieder entsperrt
WTF, ich war da gerade mit der Maus drüber, ich wollte die Nachricht eigentlich markieren
guck mal, ob du wieder schreiben kannst
Patrick, guck mal, er dürfte entsperren sein
WTF, wahrscheinlich musst du F5 drücken, dass du wieder in den Chat reinkommst oder so
Alter, ja die Leute gewöhnen sich halt nicht gerne um
und wenn du jemanden hast, der sich mit Linux auskennt und das dann auch ordentlich einrichtet
aber es hängt schon an kleinen Dingern
sodass die sich zum Beispiel irgendeinen Scheiß installieren wollen aus dem Internet, was dann nicht funktioniert
klar kannst du im Ende sagen, ja unterm Strich ist es besser, dass es nicht funktioniert
oder wenn die sich dann mal Fotos angucken wollen mit irgendwelchen Bekannten oder so
machen dann USB-Stick drauf und es funktioniert nicht richtig
wie gesagt, deswegen empfehle ich auch keinem Linux, außer er interessiert sich für
man kriegt alles in den Griff, aber halt nicht der normale Anwender, der schon mit Windows überfordert ist
mir persönlich geht vieles unter Windows richtig auf den Sack
was mir einfach viel umständlicher vorkommt als unter Linux
und was mir einfach viel nerviger vorkommt und viel inkonsistenter
Windows ist bei weitem nicht perfekt oder hat so viele Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen
zum Beispiel das Startmenü, was nicht richtig in der Suche funktioniert
oder diese komplette Inkonsistenz, was irgendwelche Einstellungen angeht
guckt euch das hier mal unter Windows an
wenn du jetzt hier deine Soundsettings machen willst, was machst du?
machst du das hier? machst du das hier?
machst du das hier?
da kriegst du das, kriegst du den alten Mixer
ich hab letztens gesucht, ohne Mist
ich wollte gucken, wie mache ich mein Mikrofon lauter
bis ich da drauf gekommen bin, ich hab's nicht gefunden
bis ich da drauf gekommen bin, man geht hier drüber
in das alte Menu Recording, sagt USB Mikro
ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo ich das mittlerweile mache
wo ist die offizielle Variante, mein Mikrofon lauter zu machen?
hier wahrscheinlich, nee, geht nicht
mein Mikrofon lauter, Windows, wo?
wo geht das? wo macht man popelige Sachen wie Mikrofon lauter?
wo geht das, Windows?
kann doch nicht sein
naja
ja, ich weiß ja, wie ich's machen kann
dass es hier drüber funktioniert, weiß ich ja mittlerweile
aber das ist noch so ein Alter, so ein oller Dialog
und das ist ja das, was ich meine, dass es komplett inkonsistent ist
und es ist halt komplett unlogisch
ich meine, ich würde erwarten, eigentlich würde ich erwarten
rein aus intuitiver Sicht, ich klick hier drauf
und ich hab zwei Slider
einen für Input, einen für Output und einen Mute Knopf oder sowas
das nächste, was ich erwarten würde ist, ich mach's auf
und dann erscheint das für Input oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
das nächste, was ich dann erwarten würde ist, ich geh in den Mixer
hab da ein Setting für Input
danach würde ich erwarten, ok, Open Sound Settings
klingt doch danach, als dass man da irgendwie Mikrofon anstellen kann
ja, man hat hier auch sowas, man kann kein Mikrofon anstellen
man hat Sound Devices, kommt auch irgendwas anderes
was muss ich machen, ich muss auf Sounds gehen
in dem alten, auf Recording und dann ist
das ist komplett wir, wie die das gemacht haben
so unfertig
und das ist nur eine der Sachen davon
das Schlimmste bei Windows ist
wieviel Leistung vom Computer nur für Windows drauf geht
aber ich find das geht eigentlich
ich find das geht eigentlich
oh man erfindet mal ein Programm
so eigentlich kein Ding, dann guck mal
ich hab jetzt ein bisschen Studio laufen
alles mögliche
ist doch
ist doch nix eigentlich
geht fast nichts für Windows drauf
was ich am meisten frisst ist OBS
VMWare und danach
danach kommt schon das Programm, was mir die Prozesse anzeigt
also Windows frisst
nicht wirklich viel
das geht schon
und ich find auch, dass Windows 10
ziemlich responsive anfühlt mittlerweile
von der Oberfläche her
nicht dass und was geht mir Windows auf den Sack
ja Cortana hab ich immer aus
dass diesen Kack hier brauche ich nicht
das ist
was soll denn das sein
mind that craft
skin
das ist kein Scherz
sie sind unsere eine Millionste Besucher
ja ja fickt euch
für solche Fälle
für solche Fälle hab ich normalerweise immer dann
Prozessexplorer auf
das kann ich dann gleich feststellen
dass sie nicht irgendwie eine Edge Sicherheitslücke
ausgenutzt haben, um mir irgendeinen Scheiß unterzuschieben
deswegen guck ich Paranoid gleich rein
Musik
benutzt du Schokolatier, ne ich benutze
Scoop
Scoop, benutze ich
das ist so ähnlich
allerdings nicht für systemweite Installation
hauptsächlich für
Entwicklersachen
was hab ich da installiert, Sevenzip, CMD, FFmpeg
Git, Hexeditor, was auch immer das ist
was ist das
ah, irgendein Setup, Geschiss
NodeJS, Postman, SQLite, Explorer
Scoop ist gut
Musik
du brauchst keinen Bing, nein Bing suckt
schau dir mal die Icons in der Management Konsone an
das ist hässlich, sieht aus wie Windows 2000
Musik
hast mitbekommen das Edge umgebaut für dir, hab ich
ja
ich weiß, was auf meinem Rechner läuft
ich seh sofort, wenn da irgendwas spawnt, was nicht spawnen sollte
ist alles im Blick
Musik
alles, alles im Blick, was bei mir passiert
das ist Visual Studio Zeug, was
Musik
denkst du, dass Linus in Zukunft gleichrangig mit
Mac OS und Windows 10 sein kann auf Desktop? Nein, das glaube ich nicht
in allen anderen Bereichen ist es ja schon weit voraus
das darf man ja nicht vergessen bei diesen ganzen Diskussionen immer
Musik
als das in den meisten anderen Bereichen schon
nicht nur Fuß gefasst hat, sondern weit voraus ist
ich mein, die wichtigsten Server im Internet laufen alle auf Linux
ja
Embedded Linux Zeug in jedem Toaster
vielleicht auch in BSD
die Playstation ist BSD, kein Linux
ahem
Musik
ja Akku läuft halt, ist auch ein Problem unter Linux
das liegt aber nicht so sehr an Linux, sondern oftmals an
komische Hex
machen und
die nicht so Standard konform sind, so wie die China Kamera
heute
was dann halt der offizielle Windows Treiber von denen wunderbar macht
allerdings irgendeine Linux Standard Implementierung nicht
Musik
wann ist es eigentlich sinnvoll BSD zu benutzen?
ah
für Server
in manchen Fällen
für
Firewall, sowas wie PFSense oder sowas
ansonsten
ich mein
die haben paar ganz coole Sachen unter BSD
zum Beispiel diese, also was PFSense ja schon lange kann
dieses Session
dieses Session Spiegelgeschichte
also sprich, ich weiß nicht wie das heißt
das sind zum Beispiel, wenn du dann
einen Loadbalancer hast und der geht kaputt
dass der sich quasi im laufenden Betrieb
mit einem Backup Loadbalancer quasi sunken kann
und damit halt nicht nur die Sachen auf der Platte gemeint ist
sondern so komplett auch Connection State und sonst was
das heißt, du merkst es wirklich absolut gar nicht
wenn der Loadbalancer abkackt
die haben schon ganz coole Sachen in BSD
ansonsten muss ich aber ehrlich sagen
ich hab noch nicht allzu viel damit gemacht
also Microsoft macht auch
ich bin kein Windows Fan
Windows ist finde ich das schlechteste
was Microsoft so macht zur Zeit
Office habe ich mir schon öfters drüber aufgelassen
Office braucht wirklich kein Mensch, gar keiner
komplett useless Office
das macht vor allem was ihre Entwicklersachen angeht
erst zur Sahne aktuell
seitdem sie da den Nadella am Start haben
vor allem das Open-Sourcing von.NET war das beste was sie machen konnten
.NET Core, vor allem das es jetzt eben auf Linux läuft
es fehlt noch
vielleicht kommt das ja demnächst
es fehlt nur noch ein richtig gutes
Cross-Plattform GUI Framework
richtig, so ein richtig gutes, richtig durchdachtes
mit der Power von Microsoft dahinter
was dann auch
was alles abdeckt
vielleicht basteln sie ja mal ihr Xamarin Zeug darin
aber da glaube ich nicht dran
dann ist C-Sharp Weltherrschaft angesagt
aktuell kannst du ja mit.NET Core das im Prinzip auch machen
da brauchst du halt einen Browser als Frontend
da brauchst du irgendwie einen Elektron oder so einen Kack
ja Proton ist nice
ich finde das gut
bei Valve haben sie ja nicht
ohne Grund so einen Zug dazu
auch andere Plattformen zu unterstützen
die finden das auch nicht so geil
dass ich ihnen dann Microsoft sagen kann was sie machen sollen
unter Windows
Sigi Bua, ja steht los
welche Text- und Datenverarbeitung benutzt du
was verstehst du unter Datenverarbeitung
Text benutze ich Wim
wenn ich einfach nur was schreiben muss
ich habe auch eine Weile Emacs verwendet
und ich kann den ganzen Flame Warme verstehen
einfach zum Schreiben verwende ich
wenn ich einfach nur was kurz sein, was editieren muss verwende ich Wim
und wenn ich was formatieren muss dann
mache ich da Markdown raus und haue es entweder
als HTML oder PDF raus
ja
Selmo Container Geschichten sind bei uns
aber gerade erst zu entkommen
ich meine ich bin bei einer Bank
bei einem Finanzdienstleister
und die sind da
was so Entwicklung angeht
sind nicht unbedingt immer ganz vorne mit dabei
was aber aus ihrer Sicht auch verständlich ist
es tut es erstmal
nicht notwendig das komplett permanent umzubauen
was benutzt du für Markdown PDF muss ich nachgucken
ist immer so selten, dass ich mal wirklich was schreibe
und was man dann irgendwo veröffentlichen muss als HTML PDF
in den Wimpler gehen
ich weiß nicht, muss ich nachgucken
ich suche dann einfach immer
wenn es so weit ist danach
ja Sigi Bua schieß los, was willst du denn wissen
muss ich ein bisschen beeilen mit beschreiben
weil eigentlich wollte ich schon vor 20 Minuten
off gehen
da braucht man gar keinen YouTube Money
YouTube Money brauchen tue ich zum Glück eh nicht
da bin ich auch ganz froh
sonst wäre ich ja schon längst verhungert
wenn ich YouTube Money brauchen würde
achso meinte anstelle von Office
ja
in Notgedrung muss ich das manchmal verwenden
wenn Leute irgendwelche Tabellen oder Office Geschichten schicken
aber ich habe keinen Anwendungszweck
für Office
wie gesagt ich bin jeder Meinung
die einzige klassische Office Anwendung
die eine Daseinsberechtigung hat
für Excel
also für den Anwendungsprogrammier
Style Typ
und gewisserweise noch Outlook
wenn man halt dieses ganze Outlook Ökosystem drauf steht
meinetwegen noch OneNote
aber von den klassischen Office Dingern
sprich das ist ja im Endeffekt Word, Excel, Powerpoint
Access und was war es? Visio
Frontpage, ich kenne auch eine Frontpage
hat eigentlich außer Excel nichts eine Daseinsberechtigung
braucht man eigentlich auch nicht
Japan Look ist nice
warum kein Latech
habe ich nicht gesagt
wenn man einfach mal ein paar Sätze schreiben will
ist Markdown einfach das beste
er schreibt
ich habe mir letztens
neuen RAM geholt für meinen Desktop PC
von 4GB auf 8GB
4G ist schon lange nicht mehr aktuell
habe es aber verpennt die Taktung
von meinem neuen RAM im BIOS einzustellen
ist mir nach ca. 4 Monaten Benutzung ein Blue Screen gegeben
und der PC startet immer
also die Taktung von einem RAM
hat ziemlich sicher damit nichts zu tun
wenn das RAM 4 Monate funktioniert hat
verreckt es dir nicht einfach bei RAM
selbst wenn du weniger getaktet hast
dann auch weniger
wenn das RAM 4 Monate funktioniert
und du nicht gerade die doppelte Spannung drauf gehauen hast
wird der RAM nicht abkacken
sehr unwahrscheinlich
da wäre er wahrscheinlich auch so kaputt gegangen
der PC startet nicht
man geht den Lüfter und so gedönst an
macht der dann irgendwas wenn du den Knopf drückst
und dann ist er am Netzteil
Max FPS sagt Taka 2
und Max FPS sagt Taka 2
du kannst jetzt auch
ganze Zeit auf diese Art und Weise
austauschen
muss ich einfach nur noch mit 50 Sachen registrieren
mit 50 unterschiedlichen Usernamen
dann kann man da auch Sätze draus bilden
Erklär das mal meinem englischen Lehrer da wohnt
in Office
ich bin in dem Gebiet ja auch kein normaler Anwender
ich finde auch viele Sachen doof
und wie gesagt
guckt euch mal meinen Desktop an
ja ich weiß Behörden stehen unglaublich auf Office
das finden die ganz toll
Lüfter geht an
ja da kannst du nicht am Netzteil liegen
was passiert denn
wenn du einschaltest, Lüfter geht an
bootet er irgendwie oder was macht er denn
du musst ein bisschen mehr erzählen
was macht er denn
macht er denn irgendwas
oder gehen nur die Lüfter an
macht er denn seinen Piep beim Start
falls dein Rechner Piep macht beim Start
meiner macht das nicht
weil ich kein PC Speaker mal dran hab
ja Caporotti finde ich auch bescheuert
dass in der Schule Office verwendet wird
Open Office ist auch Müll
Libro Office ist im Prinzip auch Müll
ich finde alle Office Programme Müll
wenn es ein Office Programm sein muss
dann ist Microsoft Office noch das wenigste Müll
aber ich finde Office Programme an sich komplett useless
bootet gar nicht
und BIOS kann ich auch nicht rein
gehen mal die Lüfte an und die LED beim Einschalten
das Netzteil kann es nicht sein
also geht auch kein Monitor an oder sowas
tja
das ist natürlich sehr schwierig
zu diagnostizieren
also wenn er schon nicht mal mehr piept
hast du vielleicht eine LED auf dem Mainboard
die dir irgendwas anzeigt
viele Mainboards haben ja mittlerweile LEDs drauf
vielleicht sieht man da irgendwas drauf
ansonsten muss man einfach ausprobieren
am neuen RAM kann es ja nicht liegen
wenn das jetzt schon 4 Monate funktioniert hat
also
ich würde mal
wenn du eine Grafikkarte drin hast
würde ich mal den Monitor an Onboard stecken
falls du eine Onboard Grafikkarte hast
dann würde ich die Grafikkarte ausbauen
und mal den Monitor an die Onboardkarte stecken
ob das irgendwas bringt
und wenn das nichts bringt
dann bleibt der im Prinzip
fast nur noch Mainboard
also das ist wirklich schwierig zu sagen
das könnte im Prinzip fast alles sein
ich muss sagen
ich hab eigentlich ziemlich Glück gehabt
wenn es um Hardware-Ausfälle und Probleme angeht
es ist mir wirklich die letzten Jahre
klar mal die eine oder andere Festplatte oder so
aber
jetzt aber über alles betrachtet
ist mir eigentlich fast nie was kaputt gegangen
in den letzten Jahren
ich hatte mal einen Rechner
und damals
hat Nvidia noch Mainboards gebaut
und das war so massiv
verbackter Scheiß
das hat mich damals wahnsinnig aufgeregt
Mainboard hatte so einen Onboard Fake-Rate
und ich hatte damals 2 80G Platten im Rate 0
also Kamikaze-Rate drinne
und wenn der Rechner abgestürzt ist
das hast du dann richtig gesehen
dann ist da quasi die Plattenzugriffsleuchte
von jetzt auf gleich hat es übelst angefangen zu blinken
und wenn ich den Rechner nicht schnell genug resettet habe
ist die Platte kaputt gewesen danach
also nicht defekt, sondern kaputt geschrieben
sodass ich Windows-Nema starten konnte
das lag an diesem komischen Nvidia-Ding was verbackt war damals
das ging mir auf den Sack
Atlon XP, Atlon XP ist ja schon gefühlt
15 Jahre her oder noch länger
lange
Mauszeiger in der Mitte
wo hättest du ihn gerne
aber geht nicht, wenn ich Desktop wechsle
dann geht der Mauszeiger dahin
da war leider keine Chance
was kannst du für Programmiersprachen
außer C-Sharp, Python, Ruby
Bash, Shell muss man können
wenn man ein bisschen was mit Lelux macht
wenn man
wenn man ein bisschen
sich das Leben einfacher machen will
das sollte man auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Shell können
wie viele Dinger schon in der Shell für eklige Dinger zusammengerotzt haben
ein bisschen C++
hauptsächlich mit Qt für GUIs
JavaScript, TypeScript
ich mag kein Go
so viel kann ich dazu sagen
ein bisschen PHP
Groovy
auch wenn es auf JVM Basis ist
ich hab ja nur was gegen Java
nicht gegen JVM an sich
Ruby hatten wir schon
keine Ahnung
das ist jetzt alles was mir einfällt
LC Power Netzteil
ja das ist mir auch schon mal verreckt
ein LC Power Netzteil ist mir auch schon mal verreckt
aber das ist nicht abgefackelt
was hältst du von PowerShell?
ist das nicht schlecht?
wie findest du Node wenn du JS und TypeScript
ich versuche es zu vermeiden
manchmal kommt man leider halt
ein bisschen in die Richtung
und dann ist es einfach
ich finde es nicht schlecht
aber ich versuche es zu vermeiden
manchmal kommt man leider an JavaScript nicht vorbei
vor allem wenn man Browser Sachen machen muss
und Node muss ich sagen ich hab relativ wenige Node gemacht bisher
ein paar Dinge, ein paar kleine Sachen
aber ich bin kein großartiger Node-Känner
bist du nicht Max von YouTube?
ja, schon
das hatten wir heute schon ein paar Mal das Thema
warum kein Go?
weil es mir von der Sonntags- und im Style her nicht gefällt
ansonsten ist Go eine tolle Sprache
gibt vor allem viele Dinge dafür
schon rein funktionale Sprachen verwenden? Nein habe ich nicht
ich habe ein bisschen mit F-Sharpen gebastelt
aber würde ich nicht sagen
dass ich damit flüssig was drin programmieren könnte
ich bin aber der Meinung
Funktionalen Programmiersprachen gehören mit der Zukunft
ich sage nicht alleine
aber zum Teil
die letzten paar Jahre hat es deutlich zugenommen
die Verwendung von Funktionalen Programmiersprachen
und vor allem dass funktionale Elemente
in normale Programmiersprachen mit eingeflossen sind
man muss sich mal die 90 sharp Releases angucken
wo wir alles eingebaut haben
Funktionalen Sachen gehören mit der Zukunft
was ich hier mache
ich habe programmiert bis vor einer Stunde
und seit einer Stunde labern wir einfach nur rum
Astro und Mainboards abgefackelt
generell Mainboards abzufackeln
wie hat er denn das hingekriegt?
was ich hier mache
Node wäre sehr gut gewesen
das kann sein
mit Node hätte ich aber schlechte Windows Form Anwendung machen können
da hätte ich dann Elektron machen müssen
was nutzt du im Markdown zu schreiben
also wenn ich einfach kurz und knackig was schreiben muss
verwende ich eigentlich immer Vim
vor allem unter Linux
ich nehme einfach das was gerade am besten ist
und für kleine Edit Sachen ist Vim einfach das beste
weil ich bin eh zu 90% hier irgendwo Terminal-mäßig
entweder Browser oder Terminal
mit dem Datei öffnen und editieren zu machen
mit.NET Core 3.0 Complacer
da bin ich eh gespannt drauf
ich habe ja schon vor 2 Jahren oder so die ersten Präsentationen davon angeguckt
und habe mir damals schon gedacht das meinen die nicht ernst
und damals war es ja auch noch sehr
ja sehr experimentell
da habe ich mir gedacht okay das ist erstmal noch nichts
aber da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf
quasi ein komplettes
und ich hoffe das Placer dann nicht mehr auf Mono basiert
WTF was haben sie sich dabei gemacht
da bin ich echt gespannt drauf
also.NET
komplettes.NET Framework im Browser
mit WebAssembly was dann hoffentlich
auch halbwegs performant ist
was ja bei der ersten Version noch problematisch war
und was auch nicht mehr 10 MB ist zum Downloaden
das könnte echt sehr nice werden
das ist richtig
Scope Code deswegen war das ja heute hauptsächlich zum testen
wie es funktioniert
wahrscheinlich werde ich das auch Webbasiert machen
ja es ist ja
im Prinzip das einzige was man machen kann
wenn man was Cross Platform haben will
und es nicht über den App Store verteilen möchte
da bleibt ja nur was Webbasiertes
da werden wir wahrscheinlich eine ASP.NET Core Backend machen
und irgendeine Progressive Web App Geschichte
falls man damit mittlerweile unter IOS
auch das Mikrofon access braucht für die Gegensprechfunktion
von der Kamera dann machen wir das als Progressive Web App
erste die ich je mache
habe ich noch nie mit rum gebastelt
aber wenn das unter IOS alles funktioniert ist das sehr nice
man kann ja mittlerweile auch wunderbar
mit WebRTC
Videos mit ziemlich geringer Latenz
streamen
auf IOS
also das ist schon nice
der Spannungswandler ist in Flammen aufgegangen
das musste er erstmal packen
wie gesagt Scope Code das ist ja auch das Ziel
dass ich das eben auf
den Tablets laufen lassen kann
vor allem auch auf den IOS Geräten
das war jetzt im Prinzip
das mache ich das ja nur zum testen
und dann wird es halt auch nicht Node
das muss dann halt eine Web Anwendung werden
was natürlich mit Node einfacher ist wenn man es damit gemacht hat
weil dann könnte man einfach den Kram wiederverwenden
ASP.NET Core MVC schonmal benutzt
die letzten paar
Programmier Streams waren ja fast alle
mit
MVC
nicht komplett weil den View Layer
haben wir mit Vue.js gemacht
passt aber auch wieder wir haben MVC mit Vue.js gemacht
also wir haben Model Controller gemacht
und Frontend mit Vue
also mit Vue.js und nicht mit
Vue.js
OMG It's Moe
ich weiß nicht ich habe ein bisschen mit Go rumgebastelt
wie im Endeffekt jeder eigentlich schon in den letzten Jahren
dass ich dafür interessiert mir hat es einfach so irgendwie
weiß ich der Funke nicht übergesprungen hat mir nicht so
es hat mir einfach nicht gefallen vielleicht muss ich mich mehr beschäftigen
an ein stück irgendwie diese Geschichte
mit Doppelpunkt gleich und
und irgendwie drei verschiedene Arten wie man variablen
war irgendwie weiß ich merkwürdig
hallo Snowly
2368 bringt es danke für
die ganzen Follows muss ich mal gucken hier
das Snowly ist am Start der 2M01
der ISO Press
und der
JGosGaming, Selmore
Ropet, PSP Hacker
ABXX
Phoenix, Okie
Kosvik, CantoBite, Kakao11
Nico mehr sehe ich nicht mehr
weil ich eh das Gefühl habe die Sachen sind so
komisch gestaffelt eine Minute 14 Minuten
halbe Stunde zwei Stunden drei Stunden
ich glaube das ist irgendwie komisch was ich glaube da lässt Streamlabs
zwischendurch immer lücken
ja den letzten Follow werde ich mal nicht vorlesen
sonst ist Monka Toss angesagt
warst du schon mal in der Mobile Entwicklung unterwegs
nicht so richtig ne
der Browser kann aufs Mik zugreifen unter IOS
ich weiß kann der Browser allerdings also dass es prinzipiell funktioniert habe ich schon ausprobiert
kann der Browser allerdings auch aufs Mikrofon zugreifen
wenn es keine normale Website
im Tab vom Safari ist es geht ja generell nur
unter Safari weil Apple
also sprich diese ganzen Features
gehen unter IOS prinzipiell nur in Safari aktuell
und mich würde interessieren ob das als
Progressive Web App funktioniert
also quasi als Web App zum installieren
ohne App Store
der Sache gehört denke ich wirklich die Zukunft auf Mobile Geschichten
und ich denke auch dass den Web Browsern prinzipiell
die Zukunft gehört was Benutzeroberflächen angeht
zumindest wenn es um Groß Plattform geht
also wenn du was haben willst was wirklich überall läuft
mit möglichst kleinem Aufwand
die beste
die beste Experience oder so
muss nicht unbedingt der Web Browser sein ja also wenn jetzt jemand wirklich sagen würde
er hat einen ganz speziellen Anwendungszweck
und baut dafür eine Native Anwendung
geh mal sowas wie Plender an zum Beispiel ja
Plender wirst du nie im Leben in der nächsten Zeit
im Browser laufen sehen
ich meine wozu
ja für die normalen Anwendungen und für Sachen die man einfach
Groß Plattform machen will dann schon
wie würdest du denn Bewegungserkennung implementieren
gar nicht brauche ich nicht die Leute drücken
auf den Knopf und dann gucke ich
ich brauche keine Bewegungserkennung
die bewegen sich die Klingel quasi automatisch
ohne dass ich es erkennen muss
Xamarin
was ich bei Xamarin ein bisschen blöd finde
ich muss Disclaimer
ich muss dazu sagen oh man merkt es geht auf 24 Uhr zu
Leute waren streben aus langsam
was ich bei Xamarin ein bisschen blöd finde ist
die haben ja den Ansatz dass sie
versuchen immer
die Native Elemente zu verwenden
das ist insofern ganz guter Ansatz
weil das so ein bisschen so das jeweilige
Betriebssystem look and feel vorhanden bleibt
der große Nachteil finde ich dabei ist dass
eben quasi den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
zu verwenden muss
also wenn du jetzt irgendwie ListView willst
brauchst du eine ListView mit den Funktionen
unter allen unterstützten Plattformen
und was mir an Xamarin nicht gefällt ist unter anderem
dass die halt immer noch was dazwischen haben
zum Beispiel hast du
halt dann einfach mal unter Linux wenn du es
laufen lassen willst ist da GTK oder sowas drunter
ich bin da kein allzu großer Fan ich glaube
eher dass es in Richtung sowas
gehen wird wie Flutter oder sowas
für so halb native Anwendungen
und eigentlich glaube ich auch dass es
noch mehr Browser geben wird in Zukunft
Patrick das stimmt
sagst du noch Overwatch nein
die WM habe ich ein bisschen geguckt ab und zu mal
aber nicht wirklich viel
Koreaner haben gewonnen das war aber eh klar
Hauptsache nicht modern und agil das klingt
nicht so gut
das mit dem Agil ist auch so ein Ding
da gibt es ja auch ganz viele Gurkos die dir was erzählen wollen
wir hatten letztens bei uns auch irgendwie so ein
rumspringen der dann erzählt hat was für geiles
agiles Team das jetzt wird und sowas
und wie oft wir uns denn zum Daily
Daily Scrum oder so treffen wollen
und wir sagten ja gut ich meine warum fragt
man im Namen drin ja manche sind nicht so
dafür dass Daily Scrum jeden Tag zu machen
warum heißt es bitte schön Daily
wir können uns ja jeden Tag 15 Minuten
hinstellen
und das erste was er jetzt machen will dass wir richtig
agil sind dass wir zusammen essen gehen
da haben wir ja alle was vorne
zumal ich ja ihr wisst ja
unglaublich auf Freizeit Freizeit
Aktivitäten mit der Arbeit stehe
ich werde gucken dass ich mich da irgendwie da vordrücke ich habe da auch keinen Bock
ich habe besseres zu tun als mich abends noch
da irgendwie hinzusetzen
gar nicht mal drum dass ich die Leute nicht mag oder so
aber irgendwann will man doch einfach auch mal seine Ruhe haben
und wenn schon will ich mir die Leute ausruhen mit denen ich mich hinsetze
und nur weil ich mit Leuten vielleicht gut zusammenarbeiten kann
und unbedingt abends essen gehen will
aber ich bin da nicht normal in der Richtung
wurde bei dir schon mal eingebrochen
ja online das kann ich jetzt aber nicht so richtig erzählen
richtig erzählen, weil dann müsste ich die Sache drumherum erzählen, das... ja.
Hast du schon Erfahrungen mit Trupal gemacht? Ne.
Spielst du noch Battlefield 5? Ich bin immer noch so verwirrt,
ich denke immer noch Battlefield 5 ist der letzte Teil und nicht der aktuelle,
aber... äh... hab ich lange nicht... hat mich nicht... wirklich so... so... gecatcht,
wie man so schon sagt, ne. Ich hab's noch installiert, aber... ich hab' lange nicht mal gespielt.
Musst du morgen früh raus? Nein, zum Glück nicht, ich hab' den ganzen Dezember Urlaub.
Also ich hatte schon den ganzen Dezember Urlaub und hab' auch noch den ganzen Dezember Urlaub.
Wie ist denn die Testbarkeit von mobilen, äh... basierten Web-Apps? Imstehen oder was?
Äh... Testbarkeit ist, wenn du's ordentlich machst, genauso wie bei allen anderen auch.
Das Problem, was du hast, ist halt, wenn du wirklich Probleme hast, die, ähm... was sie...
vom jeweiligen Gerät herrühren, könnte ich mir... also, wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer
Mobile-Entwickler, ja, ähm... aber wenn du zum Beispiel so Dinger hast, wie das, äh... Safari
unter iOS komische Dinger macht und man das nicht ordentlich debakken kann, außer man hat
einen Mac und, ähm... irgendwie, äh... wie hast du das Xcode gelinkt mit Kabel,
dass man die Konsole sehen kann für das Safari, ist bestimmt nicht so schön.
Europa hat sich, genau so, aber das sehen, äh... irgendwie alle anders.
Also, probiert ihr's Krums aus? Ja, sie haben sich jetzt überlegt, wir machen jetzt mal so'n...
so'n... das ist nur so'n kleines... ich bin ja auch blöd, ich hab mich ja dafür auch noch frei...
ich hab ja auch noch freiwillig gesagt, Jungs, mach mit, ne? Ähm... das ist... das ist quasi
eher so'ne... so'ne... so'ne kleine Versuchs... ähm... Geschichte, ob wir überhaupt in der Lage
sind, quasi... agil was zu machen und da hab ich halt gesagt, ja, mach's mit. Ich hab mich
ja sogar... wie gesagt, ich dachte ja eigentlich, dass das komplett überrannt sein wird, ja,
dass ganz viele sagen, so irgendwie, ähm... oah, ich wollt... ich... quasi... ich wollt
schon immer mal meinen Senf dazu geben, irgendwie und im Endeffekt haben sich 11 Leute eingetragen.
War halt der Wahnsinn, ne? Das heißt, ich muss jetzt da auch mitmachen, weil das fällt jetzt
voll auf, wenn ich nicht da bin. Weißte, ich hab mir so ursprünglich gedacht, so... und
wir sind ein großer Laden, ja, ich... ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele... wie viele Leute
wir mittlerweile sind, aber... das könnte sogar 4-stellig sein. Also insgesamt, wenn
man den ganzen Krempel mit dazu rechnet, so auf jeden Fall 4-stellig, ähm... ja, zumindest
sind relativ viele Leute und ich dachte mir halt so, da melden sich bestimmt ein paar
und jetzt haben sich irgendwie 11 oder so gemeldet. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mich da vordrücke,
dann fällt es direkt auf, dass einer weniger ist. Welche Board Ticket Software Jira?
Oder wie es die coolen Leute aussprechen? Jira! Was aber Blödsinn ist, weil das von
irgendeinem japanischen... japanischen Wort kommt. Kannst du einen billigen VPS empfehlen?
Billig nicht, also mit das Beste finde ich immer noch Digital Ocean. Muss halt ausschalten
bzw. löschen danach wieder. Digital Ocean-Dinger sind halt wirklich zackig, schnell aufgebaut
und taugen. Ansonsten hab ich bei so einem absolut billigen Coaster, den will ich jetzt
aber nicht empfehlen, hab ich noch einen Server, weil den hab ich mir vor einigen Jahren mal
geholt. Für 35 Dollar Lifetime hatten die damals ein Angebot. 35 Dollar Lifetimes und
der Server läuft immer noch. Allerdings, ähm, werden die SLAs von diesem Anbieter
eher in Downtime als in Uptime gemessen. Stundefische, schon ist genug. Ja, ich, wie
gesagt, ich wollte ja eigentlich auch schon vor, ähm, über eineinhalb Stunden aufgehen.
Ernste Bob Lazar? Nee, sagt mir gar nichts. Sagt mir überhaupt nichts. Wie läuft das
Management denn bei euch, äh, gefühlt nicht existent. So wie das bei vielen großen Finanzläden
ist, denk ich mir so. Also nicht existent ist falsch. Schon existent, allerdings relativ
fern der Realität und technischen Möglichkeiten. Das kann kein guter Anbieter sein. Richtig,
ist es auch nicht. Ach ja, stimmt, Hetzner. Bei Hetzner hatte ich auch mal bei der Server-Aktion
mir eine Hardware geholt. Die, äh, funktioniert auch wirklich gut. Da hatte ich bei Hetzner
hatte ich mal Glück. Da war in der Server-Aktion eine Kiste drinnen mit, ähm, Rate 10 oder
sowas. Hatten sie beworben, ja. Wie war das denn? Wann, wann, wann am Ende? Oder nee,
fünf? Keine Ahnung, nee fünf, fünf, was, fünf. Wann am Ende waren aber glaube ich
vier Platten oder so drinnen. Und, ähm, das war irgendwie, keine Ahnung, vier Terabyte
Platten oder so. Das heißt, ich hatte dann am Ende irgendwie, ich hab natürlich dann,
dann Yolo-Rate gemacht, ne. Das ist dann 16T. Bungie-Clown, was? Da ist ein Bungie-Clown
nicht laut. Hab ich doch nie, hab nie gehört. Wollte ich mal aufschreiben. Für zwei, ach
zwei Euro im Monat, ja okay. Aber sieht trotzdem ganz gut aus. So, ich muss jetzt echt mal
auf. Der Boss ist back, sagt, ich arbeite auch im Versicherung-Finanzsektor und unsere
Systeme basieren auf Technik von 1980. Ja, ist so. Die stehen da halt unglaublich auch
noch auf so alles Kobold-Zeug. Ja, weil die halt noch irgendwelche IBM-Mainframe-Geschichten
und so mal programmiert haben vor Ewigkeiten und das läuft halt. Das haben halt viele Banken
und Versicherungen und Finanzdienstleister so. Ich hatte eine in der Ausbildung bei mir,
die hat gesagt, also die hat Anwendungsentwickler gelernt, Anwendungsentwicklerin, sonst kommen
die Feministen dann klar wieder. Und die hat gesagt, sie lernt jetzt extra für uns
Kobold, weil sie denkt, dass sie damit am meisten Kohle verdienen kann. Und anscheinend
funktioniert das, die sind immer noch da und macht jetzt Kobold. Ich weiß halt nicht,
ob das wirklich so extrem ist, aber wenn es rein um die Kohle geht, ist Kobold wahrscheinlich
verkehrt. So Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt keinen Haftbefehl mehr, also kein Till-Lindemann-Haftbefehl
mehr an. Ich gehe jetzt Instant-Off. Ich bin müde. Macht's gut. Bis dann, CO.